bonsoir à tous et bienvenue pour ce
nouveau stream donc stream à stream
spécial speech est junior
enfin même passe même pas spécial
d'ailleurs speech et juniors et on va
changer le titre en fait immédiat mal et
donc on est censé être parti pour ce
live j'ai récupéré le chat je vais
récupérer le chat et on va et on va être
bon faut pas que j'oublie de m donc
chaque fenêtre et on est bon je vais
mettre le petit hosting avec la chaîne
bitstream attend des petites secondes
sur ces choses que je dois faire
quand je débute le stream qui prenne un
peu de temps
et après on va pouvoir se lancer
tranquillement aussi fait déjà dans le
chatt n'hésitez pas à écrire
j'espère que je suis sur la bonne chaîne
annonce est bon pour le moment je vois
personne
j'arrive pas à me connecter au chat bon
garçon qu'il ya un bug en fait sur
twitch parce que j'arrive pas à me
connecter
donc ça devrait partir incessamment sous
peu ça doit commencer à 18h à alors
l'échiquier on va aller le retrouver il
est là on va mettre le petit follow sur
fear ou parce que c'est le plus facile à
follow est pour le moment le chat
j'arrive moi même pas me connecter donc
peut-être qu'il ya un problème pour tout
le monde
si jamais vous réussissent à vous
connecter mettez moi un petit message
je crois que j'ai fini par réussir
on va voir ouais ça c'est réussi donc
c'est bon il va pouvoir se lancer donc
pour pour les trois heures de match
l'avenir 3h30 dans la pierre ou déjà à
gauche donc en bas à gauche et sam
sévillans qui avait été assez
impressionnant contre le petit niall
sarine les fiérots jha qui est quand
même favori de ce match
déjà il est mieux classé en termes de
l'eau sur une chaise comme il ya 4 200
points d'écart normalement fille round
jackie devrait pouvoir faire la
différence ce soir
mais bon on ne sait pas on ne sait pas
jusqu'à quand même personne dans le
tchad et je veux quand même vérifier que
tout soit bien sûr une enquête sans
m'inquiéter mais je veux juste que mon
haletant au début bien regardez bien
comme il faut
histoire de
ok donc le live est bien lancée le live
est bien lancée donc ça c'est la bonne
nouvelle - evian diffusion le live est
lancé donc c'est censé être bon écoutait
c'est censé être bon
bon alors ça c'est bon et un problème de
caméra alors c'est à dire tous partir
sasson peut pas rater le début du match
la haye un problème de connexion pour
pour fille rhodia qui est déconnectée
parce que je le vois plus une chaise
comme non plus un petit soucis de
connexion pour pour ali reza je vois des
gens que je connais dans le chat mais ça
je vais peut-être le relancer ce chat
attendait
je suis un peu perdu avec mama quantité
de fenêtres
je vois un peu de je suis je suis sûr
qu'il ya des gens qui écrivent en fait
je vais écrire un petit haut pour voir
et je vois pas mes propres messages
weatherbug avec le chat les mecs très
clairement
très très clairement j'essaie de
relancer ça pendant soixante et un
problème technique de l'autre côté
ah ça y est je vois ça y est ça y est ça
marche
je crois que ça marche ça y est c'est
bon j'ai dû relancer deux trois fois le
truc et ça finit par marcher comme ça ok
la première partie qui est lancé donc si
roja qui a l'air de s'être connectés et
qui va jouer donc contre sam sevian donc
quatre cinq cavaliers trois cas il s'est
si souvent foulée cinq espagnols qui a
valu à 6 la berlinoise detroit une anti
berlinoise des six alors comment il va
continuer rock ça ressemble souvent aux
italiennes ces histoires la c3g 6 rock
foo g7 je crois bien que ce genre de
vente et déjà été employé par sam sevian
avec le g6 fouiller cet dans les
italiennes ou dans les eaux dans les
antilles berlinoise et donc vous allez
me dire dans le jazz est plutôt pour fil
rouge a plutôt pour savions plus tôt
pour un match serré moi je suis partagé
cheyrou jacquier forcément gros favoris
3 mixant sur deux chaises comme gros
lots il est quand même favoris de la
compétition mais bon sur un match
sur un match sur un match comme ça tout
peut arriver
les côtes
je sais pas j'ai pas regardé les côtes
de l'ordinateur façon j'y crois pas trop
mais je donnerais bien 80% pour fear où
déjà il est quand même favori donc là il
fait cavalier f1 et ati esquiva qu est
ce qu on veut quand même joué avec gk
dangereuse situation rêvée saint cloud
et 3 quai à 5 pouces et 2 c5 et g3 ok il
le fait sans gk donc les pièces blanches
qui s'approche du roi et doit vouloir
jouer un petit coup de dam des deux
peut-être maintenant tour des uns est
peut-être joué même avec des quatre
aussi quoique your accueilli ces quatre
mais il peut quand même s'organiser il
gagnerait un tempo sur le pion à un fils
il peut mettre la tour en d1 après pour
le moment déjà ce que la chine avec ses
cavaliers vont ils les a bien placé mais
voyez il en face d'un mur ils peuvent
pas avancer donc d'amd de il fait un
clin d'oeil aux pions reiss est bon ça
c'était logique
maintenant le roi et potentiellement
dans la diagonale du fou est peut-être
un coup comme torah d un jouet pour le
centre quand même finalement et ouvrir
au caire à trois peut-être idb 4 est sur
c b à b avec un problème sur le pion à
cissé e-menaces peut-être qu'à bk
turquie et ses six salles pions c5 qui
tombe est sur b4 cavalli bessette
lecavalier pourrait être mal place en 17
mai donc faut aussi ce des quatre et sur
cavaliers detroit maintenant il doit
compter faire fou prend b3 fou prend b3
et là je vous avoue que je bloque un peu
on va voir crise prises ça c'est logique
il sait parler du foot cases blanches ça
peut être un problème le jour la
position s'ouvre personnellement j'aime
bien ce qu'a joué sevian le fou va
devoir auquel peut penser à ces quatre
aussi il faut en b3 contrôlerait la
casse d un mais j'aime pas trop parce
que peut-être un jour cavaliers des 2
viendra pour chasser le flou x 4 donc il
se met ici pour contrôler la casse d un
au cas où un jour il ouvre la colonne
départs des 5 pour prendre en d5 et
mettre la pression sur des trois puisque
les blancs pourront plus jouer autour
des 1 pour défendre le pion donc tour
c'est un mois sur des 5 pour le moment
il ya vous prend et puis on prend qui
comprend pas ce que lecavalier protège
la dame n'y a pas de clouage
donc les gens qui veulent vraiment
ouvrir le jeu et la colonne des uns pour
pouvoir jouer là dessus et les blancs
qui vont peut-être essayé d'échanger des
tours remettre une tour en c1 et rendre
ce x 4 inutile est-ce que cbcb et d5 une
option qui ouvrit la feda me cette
logique quelque part bouge la dame
peut-être que fait retour des 8 par la
suite et préparer des cinq comme ça avec
une tour qui sera bien placé et ce x 4
c'est un peu un simple à double
tranchant parce que d'un côté il est mal
placé mais d'un autre côté il contrôle
des cases qui peuvent être très
importante donc à voir damas deux il se
barre de cette colonne des on sait pas
exactement ce qu'ils préparent
tu as tout re des nuitées en vêtements
pour préparer un peu des 5 il fête ses 4
1 il y des séquences sur des quatre qui
on prend fou prend les carriers pr4
peut-être aller voir calculée tour 1 et
peut-être f5
waouh c'est un très tactique c'est
peut-être ça l'idée
c'est peut-être ça l'idée est donc d4
pas vraiment jouable et sur dc peut-être
baissé avec un fou qui pourra re
naviguer revenir éventuellement sur la
diagonale à 4,8 et qui est bien placé en
a quatre donc ils jouent des 4 et là les
mecs ça va être ultra tactique ultra
compliqué parce que ça va pouvoir
prendre de partout il y avait quatre ans
prises à la fin donc comme je vous dis
comprend prises qui prend 2,4 peut-être
possible
tour 20 et peut-être des cinq quelque
chose comme ça avec une position
vraiment complexe ça va exploser là les
amis donc ses cadres des quatre îles est
pas allé prendre l'option il a fait date
17 et des cinq maintenant donc chez
rhodia qui ferme le jeu vu qu'il a la
paire de fou et les noirs qui vont
devoir maintenant peut-être joué un plan
à base de cavaliers bouger f 5,6 peuvent
peut-être commencer par un petit coup de
dames 17 pour venir un peu contrôlée des
cajas dans la dame en paix c'est tu fais
plus trop sens elle tape sur deux pions
effet touré fut donc ils préparent un
peu f5 cavaliers h 2 maintenant est ce
qui va faire un petit coup de cavaliers
g8 pour préparer 5
on vous dit que le x 4 et plus trop top
maintenant ouais c'est vrai mais
peut-être un jour il pourra revenir faut
pas l'enterrer trop vite ce fou donc
cavalier g8 jouer il prépare f5 dam des
deux ans toutes les pièces vont revenir
vers la leroy faut toujours calculé truc
comme ça il n'y a pas d'âme ses deux ce
que s'ils avaient dame ces deux dames et
vii g4 gagner à tour mais le x 4 qui a
pas dit son dernier mot il encore utile
donc et uf4 pour bloquer f4 et cavaliers
hausse est donc maintenant c'est bianchi
son propre nom des 5 es là encore on
voit l'utilité du x 4 1 ou 10 et il est
vraiment inutile parce qu'ils contrôlent
la case d1 et donc d'en prendre 5
jouable
donc le pion dessin qui pourraient
tomber ici cavale et h5 on prend des
cinq jouer dame bouger peut-être fois
fuite pour garder le fou et les noirs
turin cloud plus mes positions pas
forcément simple à conclure surtout face
à ahfir ou déjà qui est très habile dans
ce genre de situation alors un petit peu
comme fois je suis tour g8 ça mange pas
de pain mais peut-être qu'il est prend
g7 est pas une vraie menace
puis on prend puis on prend donc jour ce
x 4 qui contrôle la très importante
colonne des ouverte donc tourbe et de
essaye de d'esquiver le x car être et de
passer sur la colonne des dames f7 gaye
un tempo ou pas d'ailleurs sur le
cavalier parce que f4f 3 et pas
forcément une menace sur as your adam
prend fous ces cinq villes actives sont
fous ils veulent échanges éventuellement
contre le cavalier ici le carré les
sembles avoir plus d'avenir que le fou
pour g8 il se met sur la colonne gla
c'est vrai que le pouls a cruellement
manqué ainsi l'été sur la case de quatre
ce serait fantastique tour f1 car il est
des 5
il veut venir au caire menace qui est
français 3 et attention ce que ce
cavalier h5 la dame est attachée aux
cavaliers donc ça peut être un problème
un jour
à noter la tourbe et de bien placer l en
revanche défend déjà la deuxième rangée
mais les noirs qui veulent qu'ils
avaient princes et rois et qui veulent
aussi cavalière 4 qui menacera
éventuellement l'option g2 et le pion h3
la dame qui vient à f3 tour g5 menace à
nouveau cavalier cavaliers g3 menace
peut-être le pion fc un corgi peut-être
parce qu'il faut tout raison garder
regard des détours g8 qui est pro f 5 et
voir s'il ya pas un problème sur g2 mais
apparemment non et il n'est pas facile à
défendre ce pion
tours g8 qui est pro f 5 c'est quoi
l'idée mais ce qu'il veut jouer parce
que s'ils jouent aux cayes fait cavaler
f4 donc il vient sans prendre maintenant
grâce vraiment tout reprendre tout
reprend tout reprend donc le cavaly qui
revient en bo3 qui défend tous et
maintenance evian qui doit peut-être
joué un coup à l'est d'alger 6 logique
j'allais dire pour menacer pouces et 2
au 6 mai à les pièces blanches qui
veille à c'est dommage que si si mais
ils font aux 4 c'est fini à 3 h un tour
g3s qui va faire un coup des chèques non
il ya juste on g7 qui couvre tout donc
la dame qui a peut-être revenir en f2
non il fait un coup d'échec la tour
couvre damas huit tours g8 ok ça revient
non ça gagne pas faire annuler la
sévillans qui peut pas faire nul ici est
de 4 le 4 était une option pour pour
fermer la la connexion de la dame
mais il est parti on détroit et il
n'arrive pas à créer de menaces qui
avaient plongé de maintenant jouer parce
que la dame fermes prises prix sur qui
les projets de haies dames prend f1
assure dame prenait fin qui est pro f1
n'y a pas de maths et fièr ouja qui
gagne la tour et fidjiens qui va gagner
la partie et fil rouge on a vu tout son
talent dans la mêlée tactique face à un
joueur redoutable un samse vian est un
des meilleurs joueurs en tactique du
monde 1 c'est un jeune joueur américain
extrêmement dangereux extrêmement
tactique mais on voit face à fear où
déjà il y avait peut-être d'amd un échec
là qui a été ratée attendez je vais
jeter un oeil non sur d'amd il y avait
un truc il y avait 3 h 2 tom price trois
cavaliers h4
il avait probablement vu firoud déjà
alors ça continue à jouer c'est envoyer
du jeu de partout
le roi noir qui est dans un semi réseau
mais le pion à qui est très fort c'est
bien qu'ils s'en sort pour le moment
attention ne pas laisser rentrer droit
l'ordi dit que dame pranger s'inquiète
un premier set et gagnant parce que le
pion fils adam mais c'est lyon qui l'a
pas vu s'il s'est emparé de la tour
c'était madame h41 prend 2,7 ici on ne
le voit pas assez incroyable qui rate
dames 3e set c'est pas très difficile à
voir en réalité et maintenant il va se
faire mater non d'alger cinq dames
province est maintenant il va le voir
et là il va prendre
et cette fois ci le voit la dame me fait
une deuxième dame et maintenant c'est le
pion h qui fila au il va tomber non il
réussit à jouer mais il se fait choper
le pion il va perdre encore les deux
pions à et la dame des cinq échecs qui
va traîner
il faut qu'ils arrivent d'une manière x
ou y à choper le cavale on va créer un
réseau de maths il n'y arrive pas oya
cavalière quatre échecs maintenant une
multitude de garate par les deux joueurs
dans cette partie
une partie à rebondissements est
difficile de savoir qui va gagner
des trois c'est si ce qui va arriver ça
sent bon pour les blancs maintenant le
roi qui s'échappe hills c'est plus
réseauter il n'y a pas d'échec alors ils
ramènent le roi loin attention il
faudrait peut-être mettre la dame sur
une case noire attention de pas se
prendre un échec
alors ok maintenant d'amener cinq dames
b3 et c'est fini voilà là à la suite à
la suite d'un combat de haute volée
c'est finalement alors pourquoi cette
fois l'échiquier s'est décalé j'espère
que les gens qui étaient bien depuis
tout à l'heure j'ai pas trop compris
s'était passé avec l'échiquier les
bruits que vous me ready dans le tchat
c'était vraiment une belle partie très
serrée très intense qui se solde
finalement par par une victoire de
séville ans et c'est plutôt une bonne
nouvelle pour le suspense parce qu'on
avait peur qu'allié reza survol
complètement
les joutes tactique et finalement il a
semblé nous donner raison en début dans
des bus de ajouté j'ai envie de dire et
finalement petit à petit ça me sévillans
qui a retourné la situation et
finalement qui s'en est sorti alors
d'autres pj la finale avant l'heure pas
vraiment parce qu'il ya aussi vous voyez
dans le tableau doc ph
et oui c'est pas sûr que ce soit moins
fort que c'est pas sûr que ce soit moins
fort que ces deux là en tout cas c'est
mieux classés en feed
alors effectivement ivo karlovic et ce
niveau et le niveau est bien supérieur
au speech est féminin dans ce speech
junior puisqu'on a des joueurs qui font
partie du top 100 mondial voire même
avec oui je crois qu'il est 25e mondial
donc c'est un niveau bien bien supérieur
au speech est féminin donc on est dans
cette nage dorff
je crois que ça sortait d'une âge d'or
j'ai pas bien non pas en une nage
d'orphéon ça ressemble et donc cette
caste des saints qui est un peu le point
névralgique de la position les noirs
veulent jouer des 5 et 6 béret faire
jouer leurs centres et les blancs
veulent bien contrôler la case
éventuellement un jour jouer même avec
f5 pisser sur des 5 et après envoyé sur
le roi les noirs qui jouent des cinq
mêmes donc comme on l'avait plus ou
moins prévu et de nouveaux grosse mêlée
tactique puisque surtout on prend un
saint qui semble qu'il va jouer t4 pour
jouer sur la fourchette
c'est donc déjà très compliquée
donc on va voir
on va voir comment réagissent les blancs
il semble qu'ils doivent quand même
prendre un parce que si on prend ici il
va y avoir un car elle qui va reprendre
en d5 ça va attaquer le fou ça va
attaquer le plan f4 et ça semble
extrêmement dangereux donc ça sent
battre est possible et sur qui on prend
des quatre alors là c'est le bordel
total 6 3 et 6 et c'est vrai qu'il ya un
gros problème pour les blancs parce que
si on veut garder le fou ce qu'on a
envie de faire de base du rapt en france
et trois pions français 3f france et 3
qui fera un genre de fourchette
donc la position et compliqué à gérer
pour pour pour sam pour sam saignant et
phil rogers way qui a l'air de se faire
plaisir là sur cette partie sur ce match
et l'ardèche de très bonne humeur
écoutez tant mieux ça fait plaisir de
voir les joueurs s'amusent et en
pratiquant les échecs ça doit quand même
à mon avis hein
c'est un conseil général soit pour le
chat ou pour pour les joueurs
professionnels
ça doit rester un jeu vous devez
toujours vous amuser en jouant le jour
où c'est plus le cas ça sert peut-être
plus à grand chose de jouer aux échecs
du coup pour ces deux joueurs c'est
fitch fait l'événement le plus important
de leur carrière à ce stade non pas du
tout pas du tout loin de là
là la majorité des joueurs prennent
quand même ce tournoi comme un tournoi
amical d'exhibition donc pas tellement
le plus ça pour s'amuser c'est plus une
exhibition qu'autre chose
c'est un peu comme tu vois avant
wimbledon par le tournage plus comment
il s'appelle le tournoi d'exhibition et
à et voilà c'est plus une exhibition
mais pour le public par contre c'est
plus sympa du coup ça pourrait devenir
un tournoi un tournoi plus important si
un site chien.com réussi à comme ils ont
fait par exemple vous avez vous avez vu
peut-être le fisher en daube chasse qui
est un tournoi sur internet et qui lui
décernera un titre de champion du monde
fis des à la fin du tournoi donc je
crois que quand ça arrivera en quart de
finale les joueurs se retrouveront en
dur pour finir le truc est donc ce
tournoi-là aura vraiment valeur et
donnera un titre de champion du monde
d'où un peu les les problèmes qu'on a pu
connaître aussi fait dimanche dernier
quand on l'a joué mais met donc voilà
donc ce avec ses speech est en fait tu
penses qu'ils auraient plus un format
que le phisheur random pour donner un
vrai titre à
parce que il ya les caméras des joueurs
il n'y a pas vraiment de doute quand
quant à l'honnêteté des joueurs sur ce
tournoi donc il semble quand même que ce
format pourrait pourrait devenir un
format un format important à mon avis
est que chess comme à peut-être là un
excellent format pour faire des
championnats du monde deux parties blitz
parce que sur 3 heures 30 on élimine
quand même largement le côté aléatoire
et finalement on voit plus ce qui est un
bon joueur de beats même qu'en
championnat du monde de blitz d'ailleurs
vous pourrez vous faire remarquer que
magnus carlsen ne gagnent pas toujours
les championnats du monde de blitz parce
qu'ils sont assez aléatoires et pourtant
et pourtant en speech s il a toujours
gagné haut la main parce que vraiment ce
format récompense le joueur le plus fort
il ya beaucoup moins aléatoire parce
qu'il ya beaucoup de partis et on peut
construire une victoire sur le match
donc c'est quand même le point très
positif de ce format est là notre ami
sevian il a encore un avantage il ya
égalité matérielle mais la structure de
pions lui la 2 bozilo de pions alors que
firent où déjà il en a cinq qui a que
des pions isolée avec des pions double
doublé alors c'est pas facile à conclure
pour les blancs on va voir comment il se
débrouille
l'idée est bien mais à 0 contrôle au
niveau triste je pense qu'à la manière
d' hs il faut qualifier plus de monde
pour diluer les potentiels tricheurs
ouais je pense honnêtement dogues ph que
ça devrait plus est sûre qualification
comment dire sur profil en fait et qui
est qui et des tournois pour ceux qui
veulent vraiment se qualifier après
qu'ils soient organisés sur un tueur
donc
key des quatre pas certain qu'ils
réussissent à la gagner malgré la
meilleure structure s'est jamais simple
à conclure donc
position qui forcément très avantageuse
pour les blancs mais paul on n'y a pas
de matériel en plus il faut réussir à
gagner un pion et change un peu des
pièces tour canon qui menace de prendre
ou pas d'ailleurs ce qui a valu aux
trois qui étaient attaqués huit de ces
logiques aph 5 mai de 7 mètres le pion à
f4 c'est bien jouer tous réussissent
aussi parce que si les plans prêts non
pouvoir prendre du plomb et les noirs
qui ont réussi à bien installer le
cavalier sur trois sait bien jouer pour
serra g7 kf3
ces cinq dons qui l'empêchent cavaliers
dès 4h trois îles ans il évite un peu
les problèmes avec les cavaliers icade
qui peuvent arriver donc les blancs qui
reste mieux bien évidemment mais bon
faut faire gaffe un f4 pour g6 tour g8
il peut commencer à avoir des problèmes
pour les blancs il n'arrive pas à
attaquer les pions tours 1
pour peut-être en fait ce que va faire
fuir ou déjà c'est juste d'attendre moi
ya jamais de cavalli j'ai quatre ans que
la tour est protégé mais les blancs je
vois pas du tout comment ils pressent
pour le moment ils n'arrivent pas à
faire quoi que ce soit et c'est même les
noirs qui réussissent à jouer ces quatre
détruire la structure blanche et appuyez
sur le cavalier de 3,5 les blonds et est
très passif il a essayé de s'organiser
afin de profiter des faiblesses des
blancs des noirs pardon mais du coup il
a il n'a pas du tout réussi à s'activer
l'est restée très passif et maintenant
c'est les noirs qui peuvent peut-être un
peu près c'est peut-être tourbez cette
même karelia f5 parce que revenir vers
g3 faut faire gaffe à des coups comme
tour des cinq ici quand même un coup
comme tour des 5 peut permettre
d'attaquer le pion à cinq lieux de
détention de il vaut avoir une morale
l'hapoel de la part du président de la
russie
airwatch de dons qui l'empêchent
qu'avait lieu de 120 à risque autour
d'eux tout rêve de tout re 2 peut être
une idée ça on va laisser le soin à fuir
ou déjà de calculer c'est peut-être une
option tours 2
or c'est cette est loin d'être idiot ok
là il ya un problème et à tours s'est
enfin de variantes et quand cavaliers
bouger la tourache un math à non il ya
toujours eu cinq encore mais f6 et la
torah plus de cases incroyable tour
c'est 3 et fuit tour 8,3 et vii c'est
joli vous allez voir toutes les cases de
la colonne sont contrôlés par les noirs
aux c'est vraiment joli sac à main comme
fin de partie et notre ami notre ami sam
c'est lyon qui est pas bien payés enfin
deux variantes là c'était vraiment
esthétique toutes les cases delà de la
colonne était contrôlé donc une nouvelle
petite berlinoise et la sks la cour en a
eu 2 ou en juin dont il a mais en vain
un petit peu de réussite mais il en faut
pour gagner une partie d'échecs en tout
cas c'était assez joli la manière dont
ça s'est terminé
mais c'est aussi pour ça qu'on aime
regarder des échecs et suivent un don
4.1 dame prend 1 est fou condé 4
c'est pas réfuter de manière immédiate
mais après ces trois fois fils vous
prendrez scission en d6 les blancs une
bonne position
donc c'est pour ça qu'il n'est pas venu
s'en prendre aux pions des 4 et
maintenant toujours jouable mais y
aurait du cavalier des cinq mais il peut
faire c'est comme ça que c'est en train
de continuer et donc de mémoire c'est
genre de truc je suis passé déjà été
joué mais c'est un truc que j'ai déjà vu
quand on analyse et une partie avec fab
je sais plus laquelle
les filles où vous avez vu un joueur à
3800 comment il est capable de retourner
une finale difficile
c'est ça qui est dur aux échecs c'est
vous essayez de gagner vous essayez de
gagner vous essayez de gagner et vous
pouvez à tout moment vous faire
retourner par votre adversaire
voilà une position avec donc un pion de
plus pour les noirs mais les blancs ont
un surplus d'activité un beaucoup de
pièces noires sur la huitième ranger le
cavalier ou huit qui peut plus vraiment
être utilisés 1 il est complètement
bloquée sur la 8e et donc position a une
nouvelle fois complexes les noircissent
développe auront un pion de plus mais il
faut finir le développement alors est ce
qu'un coup comme ces six envisageable
ici peut-être cavaliers c'est 3 bougez
foot est roi
pour menaces et peut-être du time iv et
avoir dû dameuse d'un match 5 pour
attaquer le royal car ayant eu cette
difficile à déloger fouet 5 jouable ici
mais peut-être dame e4 g6 bouger et 6
bouger si se bouger ci soit ça pour un
petit peu illustré avec position est
bien évidemment encore complexe à me
cède et puis ça joue mais les blancs qui
aurait une belle attaque donc on voit
qu'il ya un petit peu de venin dans la
position c'est pas si simple que ça
je joue avec les nerfs j'allais vous
dire qu'il peut aussi aller prendre b2
tourbe est un fou 5 peut-être f4 et fous
des quatre échecs pour gagner en tempo
sur le roi
tout ça est tout à fait jouable mais la
position sanvensa intéressante à à jouer
quand même pour les blancs puisqu'on en
blitz et c'est quand même plutôt les
blancs qui attaque et donc firoud déjà
on va voir si sam sévillan est capable
de se défendre face aux joueurs iraniens
alors la food & 4 ok peut-être c6
intermédiaire russie en idée puisque sur
carrillo 7 on peut prendre de la dame en
vaux 7
c'est sûrement ce à quoi il réfléchit
tout cas on va très bientôt voir le coup
qui va choisir
phil rogers a fait un cheval sessegnon
qui fait plus jeune que son âge ou
chirurgien qui fait plus âgés mais en
tout cas on a l'impression qu'ils route
jamais à 17 18 ans alors qu'il y en a
que 16 et sam sévillan a peut-être une
tête plus juvénile un visage plus
juvénile je sais pas c'est mon
impression après en tout cas il se
calcule sam
il a pris plus trop de temps ça semble
dangereux et il est bien il est bien
enfoncer dans du calcul mais il faudrait
qu'ils réussissent à jouer plus vite ce
qui est toujours facile à dire mais
difficile à faire parce que si tu as le
choix et que tu calcules sa paire en
ligne c'est difficile de jouer tout cas
y réfléchit et il commence par ces six
chiots jacky consignes qui joue tempo il
a tout calculé sur le temps de son
adversaire et c'est un peu ça le
problème quand vous mettez longtemps à
jouer un coup c'est que vous laissez à
votre adversaire le temps de calculer
sur votre temps et donc il vous remet la
pression derrière
donc
fu 17 à risquer à faire un coup de dames
f2
dames g3 je préfère il menace là et
maintenant peut-être tour f1 pour
menaces et fou prend 1,6 à mais sur quoi
est peut-être cavalier e 4.4 etam b6
échec
c'est l'idée de séville ont surtout fait
fin c'est bien joué donc ferroudja qui
va devoir être plus malin que ça
peut-être joué fou j'ai cinq cours d'un
match 4
au québec les lieux quatre sa part
intéressant il ya des f4 aussi
commencent par dame b 6
il va faire cavalier e 4 maintenant
semble logique qu'un cavalier 4 parce
que ça défend le pion des six au passage
irujo dame f4 menace d'un rêve cette
dame elle fit maths quand même il fait
agissent pour empêcher la faire très
attention des rêves ces trois là vous
prend prises et tour f 6 pourrait être
une idée pour menacer tout reproche six
fois et fils médias dame b un échec
donc pour l'ont pas de maths
pour le moment pas de date pour les
blancs
intéressant je sais pas comment
continuer ladakh ici pour les blancs ok
il prend prises et fouet f6 voilà c'est
fini adam g6 et d'un bref si cela a des
surplus bref si je vais avoir un truc
d'un prend 3,7
bonjour pas exactement ce qui avait mis
devait avoir quelque chose ouais c'est
jean qui s'est fait mater la dure la
barre assez logique donc fi rhodia qui
prend la tête et qui mène maintenant 2 2
buts à 1 je pense pas qu'il y avait
nulle bobby y avait peut-être quelque
chose
il a calculé quand même longtemps et ça
a été répondu tempo donc élise 2 3 et 4
des quatre à cinq baies 5 qui on prend
c'est pas une mauvaise ligne cette ligne
avec avec b4 je pense qu'ils avaient
quelque chose aux biches heures après je
sais pas mais à mais je pense qu'il y
avait une manière de gagner pour les
blancs en tout cas fiez-vous déjà qui
prend un avantage déjà d'un point et ça
fait un peu peur pour sam parce qu'il
avait réussi une très bonne partie pour
commencer et finalement il finalement
chez rhodia qui a très vite répondu avec
deux victoires consécutives donc les
blancs qui ont fait 1
genre de slave à couleurs inversées et
maintenant c'est rentrer dans une
structure de type française avec les
purs quatre des cinq contre trois des
quatre est donc le soi disant mauvais
foule a réussi à bien se placer alors
les noirs qui veut le faire damage 4-1
très clairement pour s'en prendre option
f2 ou d'un v6 donc oui c'est exactement
la vente à laquelle je pensais et
maintenant avec un barrage 4 qui
pourrait arriver
non il fait cavalier h six cavaliers f5
donc y revient mais là maintenant après
rock et ses 4 j'ai l'impression que les
blancs une bonne une bonne position
donc
les blancs qui attaque un peu des cinq
ans et c'est vraiment une française à
l'envers avec une position pas à pas
évidente à jouer pour les deux joueurs
donc les notes qu'ils peuvent vouloir un
peu visé le la casse ces quatre les truc
c'est qu'il ya pas cavalier à 5 le pion
et sur la casa 5 cd du coup de pouce et
5 fu pays si si si c'est jouer pour pour
tout de suite sans prendre à la tour et
à la dame faire un genre d'enfilades
janick là rien compris à la nation de
bons et mauvais fou ici pour les blancs
le pour les noirs le bon fou c'est le
fou de cases noires parce que les pions
sont sur blanc donc on va le mettre en
verre et le move est fou c'est le rouge
madame b dames c'est 8 pour les blancs
qui ont bien réussi à attaquer à la dame
qui ont bien placé les pièces à la dame
on b6 la tour en b1 qui paralyse bien le
pion bessette qui arriérés maintenant h4
qui consolide le cavalier sur la case f4
fouet fils arrive peut-être fou des 8
pour chasser la dame mais est-ce que ça
va si loin que ça la dame pas repartir
en b3 ou en b2c nord qui ont
probablement joué g5 maintenant elle
plus en blanc qui ira peut-être jusqu'en
h6 pour venir se fixer sur 7 15 h 6 sur
laquelle il sera très difficilement
délogeables
donc
est ce que si on assiste va être un vrai
problème peut-être ces quatre il veut
mettre la pression sur le centre c'est
vrai que les noirs ont du mal à bouger
leurs pièces ont sur h6 peut-être que
faire tout rêve si c'est aller chercher
le pion mais bon il y avait cette
emprise
donc il peut pas vraiment le faire et là
ils menacent fouache 5 avec les blancs
qui poserait un sacré problème que ça
ferait une enfilade sur les deux tours
donc il va perdre le pion bessette eelv
à poils longs échanges et les dames
prendre h 6
elle est blanc une excellente position
ici meilleure structure de pions tout
semble le mieux
alors
alors une question de son avis rien à
voir mais quand il énonce et de pions tu
prends tout le temps de hacher pas de f
club le fait par exemple les cas où est
ce que oui car ou peut-être il veut
s'amuser en attaquant mais moi je
reprends toujours vers le centre presque
c'est logique quand tu as des pions du
canton des pieux en fait tu reprends
tout fin tu essayé de reprendre vers le
centre ok b3 il veut s'en prendre option
à 5 très directement et peut-être fou
prendre tout reprend et ses cinq
reprises prise prises et c5 peut aussi
être une option n'est que le fou quillan
b5 donc
pour triptyque à steinsel de ce duel au
sommet bah écoute pour le moment il ya
quarante cinq 45 minutes de jeu 48 de
jeu
cheyrou déjà qu'ils mènent d'un point
mais ça me fait bien qu'ils pourraient
égaliser ici il est quand même beaucoup
mieux avec les blancs il ya pour le
moment un pion de plus déjà lors il va
probablement reperdre h 6 mais il ya les
pions à 5 et des cinq qui sont un peu
mal donc si on prend il va faire fou
prend très probablement il s'en prend
maintenant un pion un peu aux pions
aussi sait peut-être qu'un coup comme
fou mais ça tu peux te retrouver 5 peut
devenir une menace avec le clouage sur
le cavalier c6 la réponse est sûre
cavaliers prend yacoub et 5 et la tour
si elle par le cavalier se fera manger
au prochain tour donc il va devoir faire
tout reprend il a abandonné à fait pas
exactement ce qui se passe et surtout
reprend mais la position semblait assez
dramatique pour le joueur iranien donc
égalisation de sam qui revient à 2
partout et il va devoir retrouver des
solutions pour lutter dans cette dans
cette variante notre ami américain qui
change un peu il fait cavalier de 8
cette fois ci il va vouloir jouer avec
des 6 ou avec des cinq pour jouer une
position symétrique ça ressemble un
petit peu hâlé française variantes des
changes mais améliorées pour les blancs
avec un peu plus de temps
alors on nous dit c'est lyon va gagner
c'est sûr c'est pas sûr hein qu'est ce
qu'on vit encore
on y démonte écart net pour la finale du
bpt le scc un junior pour la finale du
gsc non pas d'union pour la finale du
gsc pas dû en bref la jsc ce sera soit
vlad soit femme normalement pour la
finale
suivant les disponibilités de chacun et
on aura fab demain avec moi pour les
commentaires du match de wailly et on
aura là de normalement jeudi pour pour
la troisième pour le troisième quart de
finale donc voilà on varie parfois je
suis seul parfois accompagnés dans tous
les cas j'espère que ça vous plaît
toujours on essaye de faire un travail
professionnel tout en restant conviviale
j'ai envie de dire qu'à une petite
seconde
j'ai une petite vérification
d'une chose c'est bon pas de souci donc
dit un travail de qualité donc parti qui
évolue
cavaillé f600 prend peut-être un peu
pions des 5 merci toad jeunes qui nous
offre 5 beats et donc avec 6 qui revient
vers la case 4 éventuellement ça se
passe mieux cette fois ci pour le joueur
américain que dans le pour la précédente
nadal qui vient 8 peut-être un petit
coup de dames f7 maintenant et tours à
huit qui va arriver s'ils y arrivent
baj 5 peut-être plus entreprenant il
veut faire cavalier g4 c'est logique
f3 contrôler les cases du cavalier et
firoud déjà qui va vouloir jouer sur la
colonne peut bien évidemment parce que
les noirs ont du mal à jouer tour à 8 à
cause du pion à 7 c'est pour ça qu'ils
jouent pions b6 et un an phu b5 firoud
déjà qui veut se débarrasser des fous de
cases blanches et venir harcelé les
pions c7 est à 7
donc mr jack a l'air assez rude à
écouter de la musique imagine on le vend
un peu dansé sur son live face sur son
live sur sa caméra je pense pas qu'ils
stream c'est donc la tête juste fou
prend cavaliers prend écarts et des
dessins qui va faire que séville en
trouve un moyen de défendre ses pions
ce qui va pas être simple ok l'idée
c'est que surtout reprend dame prend on
peut pas faire cailler france et 7
passes tu auras dame un échec et mat
la dame en contrôlerait les cases de
sortie du roi et donc il faut trouver
autre chose il fait avec deux ils
couvrent et y maintient son cavalier
envie en b5 donc qui menace toujours de
prendre à cette housse et cette série
qui prend ses sept en plus il rebondit
directement vers eux 6 donc ça semble
fort
ça semble très fort il veut peut-être
tout reprendre huit cavaliers prend ses
sept sur tempo et cavaliers si ce n'est
pas évident comment est-ce qu'il faut
continuer avec les noirs
ce pion ce pion c7 quand même qui est
difficile à défendre pour ces huit
cavaliers prend à 7
il semble que firent au jazz soit
gagnant et discuter avec quelqu'un j'ai
l'impression cavalier e 5 alors ès
qualité sur les i say say say dame prend
f3 non pas possible ce qui aurait pu on
prend car l epr en héros f2 hockey
français 7 qui paraît jouable et les
blancs qui vont se retrouve avec un
plomb de plus et fil rouge à qui pourrai
reprendre le dessus m'a fait quatre ans
premier kg 4 menace matt damon six
échecs croix et fluide seul coup
quasiment h3k relief 6 4 ans et 7 ouais
ça à faire un pion de plus il ya des six
qui tombe est là il a l'air d'être très
tranquille
alireza parti pour pour une deuxième une
troisième victoire dans ce match où on
n'a pas encore eu deux nuls
donc elle prend ses sets joués et ya pas
de paix rhdp tient rien alors il
récupère un pion mais maintenant le roi
noir a l'air très mal mais il faut quand
même trouver comment conclure on peut
faire damer des six dames e6 est
peut-être un coup de cavaliers histoire
de passer le pion souvent ce qui fait
déjà ça même paraît assez assez
convaincant
après faut voir s'il ya pas des dames 4
ou quoi mais ça paraît déjà assez
intéressant d'ailleurs c'est ce qu'il
est en train de jouer roi et sera plus
ou moins forcé et carhaix ya eu 6 alors
il crée une menace c'est ta meuf 8
orages et six dames g73jh son garage
cinq femmes g5 mat
ouais ça assez fort comme idée est sûre
dams et 8 pour couvrir il fera cavalier
des huit qui estiment probablement et la
dame sera mal placé donc fuir ou jack
est en train de contrôler la partie et
c'est vrai qu'on voit chanter et danser
de partout c'est un petit peu inquiétant
pour ses biens ces gens qui a l'air
d'être bien moins joyeux sur sa caméra
il a l'air d'être assez inquiet et ya de
quoi
non mais il fait leaf et il fait des
faits des petits gestes bizarres
je me demande si stream paris ce que
quelqu'un peut regarder s'il est pas en
train de supprimer parce qu'ils donnent
l'impression de parler vraiment à
quelqu'un si quelqu'un peut aller
checker ça parce que c'est vrai que ce
serait une information intéressante
nisrine parce que ça donne cette
impression en fait c'est une sanction
parce que là on a l'impression qui parle
à quelqu'un ou qui fait quelque chose ou
ouais ça c'est marrant
ou alors c'est un karaoké ouais mais
menace cavalier e 5 et sur quel projet 5
qui comprend des 5 il aura deux pions
passé lié c'est pour ça qu'il ya qu'a
réalisé 50 pour pas rentrer dans cette
finale est sûre qu'elle prend à cette
peut-être qu'il ya des trois quarts
lycées 8 paraît logique
on imagine qu'elle prend b2 ici un mais
qui prend b2 ft 6-3 la et 17
ouais donc il prend un f4 pour sur des
six pour avoir cavaliers ou six pour
défendre mais bon maintenant ça lui fait
quoi ça lui fait le pion acquis par
alors le roi va être dans le carré
car sur à 5 et prend b2 à 6 c'est mort
ou qui revient comme ça voilà ça va être
dur ça va être très difficile pour les
noirs bon pour le moment ils bloquent
les pions mais on a quand même beaucoup
là il ya trois pions passé pour les
blancs ça paraît un peu dangereux les
noirs qui essayent de secret du contre
jeu de l'autre côté 1 c'est tout à fait
logique option qui arrive en 17 et les
noirs qui essaye de créer un genre de
mur avec leurs pions mais h4 bien jouer
maintenant sur gk3 f4 et le roi
s'infiltre c'est exactement ce qui est
en train de se passer et l'idée des
blancs auxerrois prend f53 roi g53 prend
au roi prend au roi prend et on voyait
un quatrième qui ont placé qui seul est
là ne sera pas arrêtable et ça va faire
3 buts à 2 pour le joueur iranien
donc les et les iraniens qui prennent
davantage sur les américains enfin là
plutôt l'iranien qui prend l'avantagé
sur l'américain et attention parce qu'il
semble quand même que si notre ami c'est
viance mettez à reculer et à céder ça
pourra aller très vite en faveur d'ali
reza
donc attention à sam sévillan de ne pas
trop glisser tout de même on va alors à
une petite catalan cette fois ci ali
reza toujours en train de se marrer
et ces gens qui se marre pas du tout
c'est là qu'on voit quand même la marche
d'alireza il ferait pas le même sourire
il ferait pas la même danse il jouait
contre 1 hikaru ou contraints ou
contraints magnus carlsen ce serait
plutôt l'autre en face qui serait en
train de danser et de chanter
l'élantra un peu de faire la même
nankin
brice prise b3 ou gadji respecte par of
faut pas dire ça il s'amuse c'est un
enfant et qui on devrait tous s'amusent
en jouant aux échecs comme je vous
disais donc il est il s'amuse il est un
peu plus fort donc y contrôler le match
il a dû sentir après quelques parties
qui jouait mieux
n'oublions pas que c'est un adversaire
regarde pas forcément la caméra mais on
pensons qu'ils chantent un sky calcul
vite
ces deux fois fuite il frémit un peu
contre cavale et f5 main se demande s'il
ya quatre décades dessin qui avec l'idée
de ramener le carélien c4 est un plan
email terre ayant eu 4 ce qui va avoir
le l'avantagent vous faire jouer le fou
bessette way carreaux qui danse quand
ils dominent
mais ce qui change le hippie ils soient
ou pas ce qu'ils chantent les bonnes
chansons c'est un peu la question qu'on
se pose et si vous souhaitez vous pouvez
vous abonner à la chaîne enfin follow la
chaîne d'ali reza ali reza firoud déjà
twitch point tv slash alireza firoud
déjà parce que dans ce trip structure
c'est vrai que le foot et non des blancs
soient bloquées oui des noirs soient
bloquées oui c'est une manière de jouer
moi j'aime pas trop je vous conseille
pas mais après c'est jouable
enfin je vous conseille pas assez pas
forcément mauvais mais c'est mieux de
commencer par des choses plus saine que
par cela va peut-être changer la rèze
pour robert s
donc c'est 5
toujours du mage ses positions là avec
les noirs mais la cei qui regagne la
case ou quatre avec lecavalier
ça c'est fort maintenant la tour des
deux attaqués et les noirs qui vont
réussir à s'organiser menaces et
peut-être même un jour du c4 et c4
directes prises prises et peut-être ces
trois maintenant et surtout prend 1,4
puis on prend b2 et la dame pourrait pas
reprendre n'y aurait peut-être pour
france et 8 est pas sûr que ce soit
jouable c3 c'est une option après un
peut-être eu 4 x 4 dames cation b2 avec
le pion à trois qui peut sauter à la fin
c'est ce qu'il est en train de jouer
fois il avait pas fou prend à trois qui
a l'air genre très méchant aille à
leucate qui reste sans prise
donc ça semble aller encore que ces
positions là sont toujours à regarder ce
que les pions peuvent avancer
éventuellement il ya quand même trois
pions passé lié ça peut être dangereux
mais meyer aussi m6 pour jouer sur le
clouage du coup peut-être vous prendra
trois jours à bhl mais je suis loin
d'être sûr on va voir si c'est jouer
mais c'est très tactique si ça marche
sur route j'avale trouvé c'est sûr
tariq a peut-être sur m6 enfin deux
variantes
il prend 1,5 puis on prend 1,5 et des
deux probablement
qui semble être une autre option
intéressante alors je pense pas qu'il
faut prendre quatre fous prend le cadam
par quatre dans le côté où il faut
brancher 3 qui paraît pénible mais des
prend 1,5 et d2 paraît très dangereux
aussi
là c'est dur pour c'est bien parce que
si père celle là cette session le
problème qu'on veut jouer contre un
adversaire qui est plus fort que vous
c'est que vous pouvez vous faire
distancer la savait que c'est bien un
nouveau dans le dur dans cette partie il
reste combien de temps à jouer il reste
trente minutes à jouer dans la cadence
ça veut dire qu'il va rester quatre
parties derrière c'est là probablement
on sera aux deux tiers
[Musique]
deux tiers de la cadence à quelque chose
près suivant combien dure cette partie
et ça ça paraissait dangereux ok
peut-être vous prend 1,4 me dé prendre
l'un des premiers 5 adam prend d un fou
prend bien ça ça paraissait après je
sais pas s'ils avaient mieux est donc il
veut jouer ça pour récupérer le plomb c3
mais il perd à 3 donc là bilan des
courses on a quoi on a un pion passé
contre deux pions passé lié ça
normalement si le joueur iranien se
débrouille pas trop mal
il devrait pouvoir mettre en avant les
pions et s'il réussit à les avants c'est
clairement ce sera lui qui remportera la
partie parce que les pions blancs vont
avoir beaucoup de mal à passer cette
diagonale la latitude référé réflexion
au niveau de damages 4 qui peut être une
idée était de faire cinq fils un pion
envoyer des 600 savoir exactement quoi
faire et fils aurait un coût j'aurai
largement considérée pour bloquer le fou
et empêcher la poussée des pions
après pousse à 4 peut être une option
utiliser de faire juste p5 bekaert par
la suite envoyé les pions passé lié mais
j'aurais commencé par f6 personnellement
donc
il fait même si ce coût le plus humain
je dirais pas forcément le meilleur mais
ça fait énormément sens de couvrir mais
j'ai ressenti comme si parler à
quelqu'un qui achète pas l'impression
qu'ils chantent quand même je sais pas
tatis parle à lui-même
marc en tout cas je n'ai pas commencé
vion peu embrouillée ici des quatre mais
n'a pas juste des 5 à 4 des 4 il va
arriver au moins jusque avec les pions
et puis à prévoir comment les avancées
jusqu'au bout et on voit déjà à pourquoi
pas maintenant peut-être un petit coup
de pouce et cette dame 7 pourquoi pas
donc on v6 d'un point 4 probablement
c'est chose faite
mais ce que cette finale et si simple je
pense sur tout reprend tout reprend il
veut dire qu'il réussit à ramener son
roi pour encaisser des cinq je pense
mais peut-être qui peut quand même
défendre
il pousse à sémalens l'idée de ces vian
c'est que quand il fera 17 ha mais le
roi pourrait à revenir comme ça hein et
sur wave 5 il a tout reprend 1,4 et du
coup ça va rentrer dans une finale nul à
troyes compte de alors fi route j'avais
encore la joue et c'est la tour prend
1,4 probablement par il va attendre pour
le faire face on le fait quand il veut
entre il le fait maintenant et h 4
échalotes 80h quatre échecs direct
d'ailleurs mais bon
donc il a bien tenu en ce qu'il était
mal c'est bien il avait un pion de moi
donc
ça a fait un nul première nul du match
et grosses des fausses grosse défense de
séville en pardon qui était vraiment
très mal qui est quand même un peu moins
bien la sortie d ouverture
systématiquement bon là il semble qu'ils
vont faire un nul on va pas vraiment
comment progresser attention ne pas
tomber quand même de pas s'endormir
ok sur tours ici où l on voit là il sut
retour ici la tour reviendra en p3
imagine
ah non il y aurait carrément une tour
fois le pardon fausses infos que je
montre quand même
ok si on vient comme ça les blancs on
peut faire tous rêvent six échecs et sur
roy prend n'y aurait pas tu donc ça
c'est une autre une autre idée de
défense de de sam saignant cette défense
avec pat cyr ou dja qui réussit vraiment
pas progressé à cause de ses deux pattes
ok s'il veut tenter quelque chose faudra
jouer avec f st avec g5
mais il n'arrive même pas à l'organiser
il arrive pas organiser g5
c'est sa seule chance hein
non il faudrait faire avec le roi plus
haut mais il n'y arrive pas c'est jean
kiffer la nuit vraiment c'est vraiment
tranquille au kg 5 maintenant tu veux
tenter quelque chose mais à tour échec
en b6 et le roi qui va venir angers 4
hockey est maintenant sur f2 3 m3 autour
des 2 on prend et ça va faire nul
allez une balle nul de combat et on en
est donc à combien on en est donc à 3 2
il reste 23 minutes de jeu donc il reste
deux ou trois parties en réalité un une
partie là qui a duré une finale qui
était nulle et qui a duré assez
longtemps donc de nouveau ce est
berlinoise
et cette fois ci c'est lyon qui vient
pas prendre le pion eu 4 qui joue le
coup des six donc il va retomber dans
une espagne plus classique corps qu'il
avait déjà joué à 6 au 2e en troisième
en fait ouais c'est un baume à tuer vos
karlovic itx qu'on est en train de
suivre match accroché de haut niveau qui
pourrait être un match de ce pitch s
adultes honnêtement vu le niveau de jeu
si vous êtes ici sur cette chaîne pour
la première fois n'oubliez pas enfin
n'oubliez pas sachez qu'on va faire
énormément un marathon de stream en
juillet et en août
vous pouvez retrouvez vous retrouver sur
cette même chaîne dont tu auras les
speech est junior
donc là on est on vit le premier quart
de finale en direct et y aura les demi
finales et la finale mais surtout on
suivra à partir de vendredi le grand
prix fidh à yuma là qui fait partie du
cycle pour le titre de champion du monde
où on suivra le numéro un français
maxime vachier lagrave donc ça durera 12
jours ce sera tous les jours c'est un
tournoi
donc ce sera dur
12 au 24 juillet si le français se
qualifie bien évidemment et en août on
suivra deux gros événements sur cette
même chaîne
on suivra la le championnat de france
adultes donc avec tous les meilleurs
joueurs français
sauf le numéro un malheureusement mes
donc ce sera le sait le championnat de
france qu'on suivra masculins et
féminins et on suivra aussi à en soirée
l'as sin que phil cup donc il ya un
tournoi qui fait partie du circuit du
grand duché ce tour qui se joue à saint
louis et il sera commenté sur cette même
chaîne en direct donc ce ne sera pas moi
sera fabien normalement mais ce sera là
aussi sur la chaîne chaise comme fr et
ce sera quelque chose comme du 15 au 28
août ou du 16 au 29 quelque chose comme
ça donc n'hésitez pas à follow la chaîne
c'est gratuit en plus
et ça vous permettra d'avoir des
notifications lorsque l'on commande ces
tournois donc ça c'était pour la petite
page entre guillemets pub des prochains
stream et donc on continue cette
espagnole et donc à tourbes et 8
est ce que les noirs veut jouer pour b4
mettre la pression sur le centre guy
roux jamendo avec les pièces blanches
aux pieds rouges a pour le moment qui a
pris davantage avec les blancs qui fait
à trois ils évitent toute velléité de bk
dont cavaliers à 5 maintenant est
peut-être le cavalier peut-être le plus
en ses cinq plus tôt est ce que c'est un
coup ici donc voilà qui fait souvent des
gestes comme ça avec les manches et on
sait pas ce qu'il fait c'est comme si je
sais pas s'ils parlent je sais pas quoi
il parle en fait dans mes champs tweet
banon mais c'est
faites y adhérons je suis surpris de ou
alors c'est du rap
ou alors c'est du rap
non ça va être du rap c'est pas possible
paris jean d'un truc de gouaix ça
ressemble à du ai'a nakamura je pense je
pense qu'ils chantent du ai'a nakamura
ça sens à 100 ça sans être ça en fait je
pense qu'on a on a détecté en fait non
c'est du haryana camurat ça a l'air
d'être pas terrible ce qui chante brel
cfi route chadjaa c'est ça c'est ça on a
trouvé les mecs c'est firoud djadja non
c'est sûr c'est du aérienne à kamra
c'est sûr ça y est on a compris les mecs
donc cette position qu est ce que ça va
donner est ce que les noirs peuvent
essayer d'envoyer un fou prend h trois
pions prend elle-même dame prend
éventuellement pour faire du cavalier f4
aller mater en force à l'ancienne ouais
c'est du nakamura
c'est sûr non mais c'est sur les mecs
laissé tomber
c'est pour ça qu'il m'a menacé de mort
car on en fait c'est parce que je chante
pas je chante pas du nakamura
on a compris les mecs on a compris
j'adore qui en d1 ce qui plombe tout
proche trois cas moi j'en verrai quoi je
vais aller advienne que pourra gens
voient est ce que c'est bien on voit sa
voix le visage de fil rouge à weepu
récit souhaiter à fuir ou de jade jarret
annoncé chirugien csu a séduit c'est dû
à lille raisin camurat en fait c'est du
alireza nakamura ça et on a trouvé c'est
un mélange de haiyan un cas murray de
hikaru nakamura et ça te donne
alireza nakamura ça c'est un nouveau
truc quoi donc avec son avec son tube de
l'année firoud jah jah
ah non clairement clairement va bientôt
sortir dans les bacs ce dans les bacs
remixé par ludwig la vie aura bientôt
voir le remix qui va sortir dans les
bacs en france
arrêté le fils caché d'hikaru hedayat
hayart position compliquée une nouvelle
fois les noirs qui ont quand même bien
placé leurs foules foucher 7 qui domine
un peu le foie h41 plus utile il faut
aussi ce qui domine un peu le flou eu 2
ou en tout cas qui est mieux dans le
conflit et le cavalier h5 qui est mieux
pour venir vers être 4 aussi
donc d'un bessette est là et qui va
jaillir peut-être un f4 à tout moment le
fou en a eu cinq ça peut ça peut venir
il peut aussi avoir du g5 foucher trois
quarts à l'étranger 3 pour casser la
structure de pions donc là il fait tour
s'est vite ce qui veut éviter les
problèmes sur le pion c'est cette c5 en
france et 5
je pense qu'avoir un g5 à un moment
donné quand les camps les blancs
n'auront plus de menaces ou g3 qui
étrangers 3 et ce sera forcément quand
même un avantage voir avec une meilleure
structure de pions une nouvelle fois
mais la partie qui peut s'emballer
sévillans qui est mal autant une
nouvelle fois on a l'impression qu'en
deuxième partie de match ferroudja un
petit peu accéléré et donc pas évident
alors dame b 6 on menace g5 foucher 3
qui a ébranlé 3 il y aura un clouage
c'est dur pour pour fuir ou de jacky
encore un peu moins bien je dois dire
que jusqu'à maintenant j'ai l'impression
que les milieux de jeu sont quand même
dominé par sevian donc on voit la route
qui reste à faire aux joueurs iraniens
par rapport au top niveau
c'est vrai qu'ils se fait quand même à
mon avis il est plus fort que lui dans
les petits dans le petit jeu tactique
mais en milieu de gens stratégie j'ai
l'impression que c'est le joueur
américain qui est légèrement au dessus
je sais pas ce que vous en pensez mais
c'est vian qui a un peu trop lent qui
round jackie est plus rapide plus
tactique
ces tueries faire g5 plus tôt quand même
sevian screen en train peut-être de se
faire un peu contré le cavaly kirghize
la casaque 4 mais peut-être un coup
comme dames 4 pour les blancs pour
attaquer le cavalier contrôler la case
f4 peut être intéressant
le cavalier qui aurait plus massive à un
maximum de charisme et d'amd de avec la
même idée cavalier e set et maintenant
les noirs qui masquait prend ses 6 quand
même
sans que que ces gens et quand même un
peu trop lent c'est pas du 5 plus de cdu
5 + 1 et ça fait une grosse différence
un incrément d'un secondes d'une seconde
ou de deux secondes au tour des 5
donc il veut nas de gagner le pion aux
cinq maintenant peut-être qu'à y penser
si c'est une menace aussi puisqu'il ya
plus le clouage effectif du flou sur le
cavalier plus que 50 secondes pour fear
ou jack est en train de voir son avance
autant s'évaporer comme neige au soleil
fondre plus tôt comme comme neige au
soleil
enfin on va dire que l fond comme neige
au soleil après l'eau qui s'évapore
comme au soleil du coup donc un avantage
qui s'évapore comme le soleil pour fear
hodja alors on nous parle de f4 dans le
chat mais sur f4 robic poilus à cavalli
prendre ces six je pense avec un gros
problème sur le cavalier fille round
jackie est mal plus que 15 secondes pour
le joueur iranien
il s'est complètement fait vie c'est
peut-être l'égalisation qui est en cours
alors est ce qui peut prendre 5 y aura
la dame qui prend prise prise prises et
peut-être fou des 6 à la fin a dit
lecavalier qui gênent pardon je me suis
emballé dans la vente que je calcule et
mais il ya peut-être jusqu'à vallée
processes du coup voilà c'est sa prise
prise c'est ici c'est sûr tour des 8 3 g
7 ou 8 fou des six échecs roi g1 et il y
aura dames c'est un attention quand même
parce que ok mais après fou g3 déjà il
ya plus de menaces de maths
maintenant le roi peut repartir vers et
fils et surtout j'ai eu 3 et 6 vous
prendrez si sûr encore une petite prise
en f2 sur échec ça c'est agréable là
pour le moment il n'y a pas d'âme tchic
tchac donc il récupère un peu de temps
il prend il n'y a pas tout reprendre des
six
allez on refait quelques échecs non il
en fait pas il en a fait karim et la
dame en g3 maintenant ils menacent ici
récupère des pions d'un f4 et g5 h5 tout
est protégé ici on prend 1,4
h4 d'alger 3 h 3 n'ont peut-être pas
d'âme g37 sert à rien puisqu'on garde le
plus récent est protégé et sévillans qui
une nouvelle fois réussi à égaliser
pour le moment le match et quand même
dominé par ali reza dans le petit jeu
tactique mais c'était bien qui est celui
qui réussit à mener les parties de a à z
serre que c'est lui c'est sevian qui
peut mener un avantage stratégique et le
mener jusqu'à la fin de la partie
là le match le scénario quand même un
peu avantageux à fuir ou déjà on sent
qu'il est un peu plus fort mais c'est
vian qui est pas si loin
il n'est pas si loin les 200 points elo
de différences se font pas forcément
ressentir et on est probablement en
train de vivre ici la dernière partie du
match en 5 + 1 quoique pas sur ça dépend
combien ça dure mais c'est peut-être la
dernière partie de cette cadence sait
bien qui fait pour le moment un match
correct c'est le match qu'on attendait
de sa part on avait peur qu'ils soient
un petit peu un petit peu juste mais
finalement non finalement non le match
est serré et ça pourrait se jouer en
plate et célian qui m'avait l'air d'être
d'anjou ambühl est surtout un plus un
donc firoud déjà favori oui mais phil
rogers
grand vainqueur facile non il faudra
quand même montrer quelque chose pour se
débarrasser du jeune américain qui avait
joué dans une pub je crois quand il
était jeune
vous allez me confirmer sac dans le chat
alors on rentre dans ces petites finales
de type catalane où les blancs ont donné
un pion mais le développement est
extraordinaire puisque toutes les pièces
blanc joue cependant les noirs sont
quand même solide personnellement vu le
nombre de fois que j'ai joué ce genre de
truc avec les noirs je préfère jouer
avec les noirs mais bon c'est tendu
alors attention les amis parce que le
bullet c'est pas tout à fait le 1 + 0
c'est un bullet en 1 + 1 c'est un bull
est légèrement différent qui peut qui
peut amener des surprises
donc il faut pas de but en blanc comme
ça effacés le joueur américain et ç'a
toujours été du un plus à un couplet le
problème c'est qu'on a des fois ce genre
de position avec un fiancé en sait
quelque part donc ça sent quand même
être un vrai avantage pour heures
les noirs qui réussissent à mettre le
pion au sein qui vont faire foule 6 et 6
et qui vont avoir un vrai pions plus
elle serait que fil rouge à s'arrêter de
chanter
il va falloir qu'ils se méfient un donc
cavalier à 5 coups souvent assez typique
parce que ça pour ça attaque le pion
bessette
si on joue b6 fekkai via ans et 6 donc
ça immobilise un peu ce fou et ça vient
faire un double rôle avec le cavalier et
le fou sur le pion bessette donc tourbe
et 8 c pour libérer le défendu le
développement habituel du feu éventuel
est habituel du fauve est réussie c'est
les blancs qui joue à trois pour jouer
pour b4 et du coup prendre un petit peu
d espace à l'ale dame est cependant à
cas l'impression qu'ils ont un pion pour
pas grand chose
2 - les blancs les noirs qui s'organise
petit à petit on va voir
enrichir ou jack un des meilleurs
joueurs de bullet du monde on l'avait vu
dans le championnat du monde de bulles
est justement c'était le seul à avoir
réussi à inquiéter hikaru donc ferroudja
qui sur internet en tout cas serait
peut-être numéro trois mondial en blitz
derrière en bullet pardon derrière
magnus carlsen hikaru nakamura
ce serait peut-être le numéro trois
mondial mais on parle là de bull est un
plus zéro et pas de bulle est un plus
trains qui sont deux cadence
complètement différente
1 plus 1 la seconde de plus de chance
beaucoup de choses et donc fuir ou déjà
qui a réussi à compléter son
développement par le couffo aussi ce
donc c'est clairement un avantage pour
les noirs ce pion plus mais c'est vian
qui va essayer de trouver du jeu il joue
p 5
il s'en prend directement au pion c est
sûr qu on prend peut-être il souhaite
jouer de 4 pour attaquer le caler des
cinq qui soutient le cavalier c7
donc c'est probablement l'idée de samse
vian avec ce b5 et on va voir comment
firoud déjà réagi mais sévillans qui a
trouvé un petit une petite idée tactique
intéressante ici alors qu'on voit la
prédiction de l'ordinateur qui pensait
donner 70% de chances de gain affirme
dja et 30% seulement à séville en moi
j'aurais donné 80 à 20 et il est vrai
comme vous l'avez dit le gros avantage
de fuir ou tchad après l'ordinateur
c'est dans le 1 + 1 mais soyons tout de
même prudents alors fi round jackie a
décidé de donner la pièce pour avoir
quatre pions et c'est vrai qu'à pioncer
beaucoup cation pour la pièce c'est
beaucoup ça qu'il a les trois pions
passé lié là il a encore un pion en veut
ouais
non vous un les noirs qui vont envoyer
peut-être b5 b 4 ap cinq têtes il a ça
casse c'est 5 il faut être un peu
précautionneux
est ce que fit route des favoris pour le
tout en un an je pense que oui est plus
fort quand même
après le problème de wailly c'est sa
connexion internet
donc s'il a une connexion internet comme
pour le match précédent qui coupent tout
les toutes les dix minutes
il n'y arrivera pas contre fille ruth
jamais oui avec une bonne connexion
internet fait quand même partie du top
25 mondial
il doit quand même être un peu plus
forts et ce sera normalement le la de la
demi finale qui nous est promise
puisque wii aura un quart de finale
assez facile relativement facile contre
vente forest et là encore attention
simplement à la connexion internet sert
khoury gros favoris mais une nouvelle
fois ci les déconnecter hadoop à tout
bout de champ ça peut devenir un
problème
donc là toute la question des blancs
c'est comment réellement arrêter ses
pions parce que c'est vrai qu'ils
avancent cavaliers c5 et il se passe
quoi sur b si si si haut qu'il y avait
le truc en d5 emprise
il fait bêtement à 2
ok sur b6 et la tour aux sources et 6
aussi les torts qu'on utilise en effet
tour c1 il arrête le pion mais c'est pas
dit de savoir comment comment le faire
avancer ce pion à deux pas ce qui peut
se faire capturer alors pas tout de
suite parce qu'il ya le fou qui le
protège mais quand même on dit les
blancs sans le bien gagner en voix et
quand même quatre pions 1
mais je suis d'accord avec des gros bide
poilus positions complexes
mais on est loin d'être sûr que ce soit
gagnant pour les noirs cette histoire ok
donc échangé une paire de tours ça c'est
bien ce que j'avais envisagé aussi parce
que moins il ya deux tours pour les
blancs qu il est difficile de couvrir
cette case maintenant est ce qu'un coup
comme fou ces trois envisageable pas sûr
puisque il ya peut-être fou des 5 fu des
cinq cavaliers des cinq cavaliers
revient et carrier princes et rois qui
est un vrai problème donc difficile
d'arrêter le pion puisque tours b1 est
une vraie idée ici pour les noirs donc
pour le moment il n'y a pas de vraie
menace mais à cavaliers des cinq qui
rôdent chasser le cavalier mètres la
tour en b un faitout rhin et maintenant
peut-être fou des cinq cavaliers des
cinq pour choper le cavaly bessette ou
le cas échéant mettre une tour en
dernier sur quatre des cinq attention
peut-être prise prise et qu'à rallier
ses cinq as mais surtour bernia pas fous
ces trois parce qu'à clouage ouais donc
c'est très dangereux pour les blancs sur
qui a été 5 quelle est la défense du
pouf s'était offerte au roi de ton en b
7 et jouer cette finale avec deux pions
de moins mais la paire de fou est un
pion à qui a du mal à avancer c'est
peut-être finalement la meilleure option
sur cahier des cinq de prendre ce pion à
2 essayer de défendre les deux pions
moins on va voir ce que fait sam sevian
il a pris prisé tour à 6 donc ils
bloquent le pion et il attaque le fou et
avec sa tour donc sur la 6ème ranger et
le pion à 7 qui peut plus avancer
ouais pas si simple que ça à conclure ça
là mais il faut que ces viandes ou plus
vite
c'est vraiment important parce qu'il a
vraiment plus de temps et là un coup
comme cavalier b4 ou cavaliers pk toile
semble dangereux et que menace de
cavaliers bouger fous ces quatre ça
semble très très très très dangereux
pour l'américain il fait cavalier quatre
équidés fous ces quatre tours c'est 600
pages fait un an qu'ils allaient prendre
les deux rois pranger deux tours pro un
abandon et on sait pas si c'était la
dernière partie ou pas parce que on a un
petit décalage avec le temps ou s'il y
en a encore une non ça a dû se finir à
la seconde près et donc il reste une
dernière partie de cinq plus un avantage
pour le moment affirme déjà dong qui
mènent 4 à 3 et qui a encore une fois
les blancs
mais si rouge à je pense qu'avec les
cations pour la pièce ils étaient pas
moins bien je pense pas qu'il y ait de
retournement de situation en sept ans
est parti les camions semblait quand
même très fort les mecs faut pas
exagérer les joueurs à ce niveau là en
speechless avec les caméras sont pas en
train de tricher n ya pas eu encore de
problèmes en ce pitch est en tout cas
pas avérée les parties sont assez assez
cohérente il ya des erreurs beaucoup
d'erreurs même je pense qu pas de
paranoïa
quand les joueurs sont filmés à la
caméra y'a quand même déjà eu une grosse
blessure je me demande est ce que vous
prend au fc 3 prend cavalli g53 et fuit
dam des trois noms mais là c'est pas
suffisament c'est toujours chaud pour
regarder ce genre de tactique
non là normalement il n'ya pas lié à des
soucis sur d'autres tournois quand les
joueurs sont pas filmés quand ils sont
très nombreux mais là pendant trois
heures et demie ça paraît quand même
compliqué à faire après c'est peut-être
déjà arrivé on n'en sait rien après 1
pas le coût des blancs des cinq baixas
lecavalier y prendre l'espace et il veut
jouer à l'ale dame
j'avais un parti c'est fini trois
secondes avant la fin du timer official
ouais alors j'ai passé une bonne idée
une bonne nouvelle pour fuir ou jo pour
ces gens que ça joue encore même élan 5
+ 1 c'est plutôt la cadence de ses vian
donc il faut avoir envie d'essayer de
recoller aux de recoller au score
on va avoir en tout cas un match qui
tient pour le moment toutes ses
promesses donc le carélien bessette qui
est pas forcément bien placé puisqu'il a
les oreilles coupées par le pion et le
pion des six aussi qui bloque le
cavalier mais les noirs qui pourront
jouer éventuellement soit pour des cinq
soit ingérable façon que c'est une
position saine ya le pion de 4 qui est
un petit peu attaqué les idées de
quadrillage cinq cavaliers f4 comme on
les a vues précédemment
peut-être même un truc comme dame ses
sept cavaliers des huit cavaliers e6
pour se replacer la dame qui pourra les
verbes et 7 dans un rêve peut-être même
le fou en b 6 dons pour la safer exagéré
et si dame c'est ça qui est des huit qui
réussissent dame bessette c'est déjà
sympa mais ajouté 5 très rapidement il
contre attaque au centre fou g5 donc
cloud lecavalier est ce que tu en
profites 4 est possible ici qu'à valider
de il joue très vite la fir où déjà il a
pris beaucoup de temps
le cavalier d2 qui re menace cavaliers
prend 2,4 sur sa demande s'il y avait
des six défend avec liés sur quels
points quatre épreuves quatre dames
prend des huit tours prend des huîtres
ou prend le 4k il prend le cas de vous
prendre des huit tours prend des huit
donc été six qui défend le pion et qui
est d'ailleurs joué par le joueur
américain cavaillé g3 qui vient rajouter
une pression sur ce pion et maintenant
peut-être un coup de décalage avec la
dame comme dame c7 qui permettra
deux des clous et la dame et de venir
mettre une pression sur le pion c3 on va
voir mais la position semble assez bonne
pour le joueur américain ici à mettre un
coup assez logique donc pour ces huit
aussi avec l'idée de mettre la pression
sur le pion c3 rien qu'ils oublient les
ans au moins égaliser mais je crois que
c'est vraiment minimum égaliser je pense
qu'ils sont un petit peu mieux ici ils
ont un pion de plus pour le moment le
pion qui est difficile à récupérer les
eaux déjà qui chante dès qu il al
avantage très heureux d'être devant au
score mais dimanche est un abricot qu'il
a pris et ce avec l'appui en c3 qui va
rester en l'air on nous dit à 4 va
sauter wave 4 face au teme c3 va sauter
aussi sûrement
et en plus on pourra jouer avec du f54
un jour donc tour à des 1 met un peu la
pression là il faut qu'il fasse gaffe à
un moment donné peut y avoir un échange
en tout reprend des huit qui des
vieilles pourrait garder le pion c'est
bien écrit pas très souvent associées
comme ça quand tu gagnes rome
franchement je vois pas où est le
problème il enfreint pas les règles il
ya quand même des choses plus graves
y a pas de règle interdisant de
sautiller ok donc ferroudja qui a laissé
le pion mais qui maintenant obtient la
contre attaque classique du fou de
l'italienne ou de l'espagnol comme ça
qui est revenue en b3 et qui attaquent
le rock avec les fous de couleurs
opposées ça favorise la tacc alors ici
je crois pas que dame prend gysi soit
une menace parce qu'il ya tout reprend
ses trois mais maintenant il ya dame
prend g6 incroyable la gaffe de ses
biens c'est la première grosse gaffe
avec du temps il ya eu des gaffes avant
il ya eu des gaffes avant dans le match
mais c'était sous sous pression du temps
mais là c'est une grosse gaffe qui vient
d'arriver avec pas mal de temps la
pendule alors d'amd ce qu'on peut faire
tour 3 ici bêtement je serai très tentée
personnellement par tour où trois
équipes et de mettre la tour en g3 et
surtour c'est un rouage deux peut-être
la dame prend f2 et on n'a pas le temps
de faire tourner trois causes de dames
j'ai un match c'est probablement le
problème et surtour des uns et la dame
prend d un échec bien évidemment
donc pas si clair il fait tour 3 et là
on va voir ce qu'il a prévu sur tours
c'est en a - f2 parce que ça va arriver
de la part de niall de de samse vian la
tour cn am3 am2 ça paraît quand même
être la manière de continuer à noter que
lorsque la dame viendra en f2 elle
protégera le pion f7 après on aura
peut-être du tour des 3 mesdames f4
échec je pense que ça devrait aller
en tout cas c'est ce qu'il faut tenter
parce que ci fais pas ça il ya juste
tour j'ai 3 à 0 contre je il fait en d1a
ok c'est une autre idée fou prend d un
pion pranger 6 pour entrer dans la
finale c'est aussi très bien joué
j'avais pas vu cette idée d'amener un
ton gratuite et qu'il allait prendre le
père pète ça lui mathieu n'est donc il
ya un an il rentre dans cette finale
aller peut-être un petit peu mieux pour
les blancs grâce à la structure de pions
quand même ce pion aux cinq qui est
bloqué sur sa propre couleur mais à
faire j'ai trois rois g23 f3 peut-être
un jour on obligé de jouer g5 et droit
pour essayer de rentrer sur les cases
blanches
si le pion était obligé de venir angers
5 donc partis qui pourraient un petit
peu dur et même si objectivement ça doit
être nul
il n'y a pas de raison de ne pas la
jouer avec les pièces blanches et donc
ça va forcément continuer pierrou déjà
qui va tenter d'accentuer son avance au
tour ces trois
et 4
des cadres 4 saint priest pour des six
échecs cour savait que 4 c'est bien joué
il veut activer le fou éventuellement
bon et ça c'est nul
ces trois fous prend 4 et 5 il va
réussir à troquer sa contre ça m leroy
ici couvrir les pions à ça pour pas du
bon côté
normalement le roi doit être là
le roi doit couvrir quand vous jouez une
finale de foot couleurs opposées
le roi doit couvrir l'endroit où vous
êtes en minorité serre que le roi ici
doit être en effet 6 si le roi est en
effet si c'est pas si simple à faire
annuler il faut avoir le temps de faire
fou c'est bref ou c5 j'aime attaque le
pion la békaa très vite courir parle
avec le roi
et s'il arrive là avec le roi c'est nul
ok puis on prend pions prend et roi des
six le roi doit défendre ici arrivant à
m6 le roi arrivants f6 et c'est fini
tout de suite important de retrouver le
roi du bon côté donc nouvelles parties
nulles
c'est plutôt pas mal du goût pour ces
viandes de jouer cette partie en plus
puisque ça lui a permis d'utiliser les
noirs une fois de plus on va mettre une
petite page de pub et on va partir faire
une petite pause avant de se retrouver
pour une nouvelle heure de jeu en 3 + 1
donc le match continue bien évidemment
j'en vois la petite pub qui fait du bien
et on se retrouve dans 5 minutes même
endroit même heure par même endroit en
fait même heure on va pas changer
d'heure même endroit pour la suite du
match a tout de suite élite
[Musique]
alors les mecs on est de retour
on est de retour le match n'a pas repris
on va réussir on va reprendre un peu le
le cha donc demain le match sera 17h01
donc attention de pas vous planter et le
match qui reprend donc on est juste à
leur fantastique pour le retour avec fil
rouge a donc qui mène d'un point et ça
va donc
ouais c'est donc reparti pour une heure
de 3 + 1 vous voyez en dessous de la
tête des joueurs en dessous d'eux en
dessous de moi même de ma personne vous
voyez le les joueurs et en dessous des
joueurs envoyés les scores donc en 5 + 1
c'est la première cadence qu'on a joué
alireza firoud djia a gagné cinq points
à 4 et donc maintenant on passe pour la
deuxième le deuxième segment du match en
trois minutes plus une seconde par coup
et on est parti avec une sicilienne avec
fille roja qui vous souvent ces systèmes
un peu chez venin qu'avec g prend et six
qui sont ma foi très dangereux mais à
mais ferroudja qu'il joue très bien il
est très fort en tactique
il calcule bien la position très
compliqué très déséquilibré le roi noir
qui va souvent restés au centre
d'ailleurs h5 c'est pour éviter que le
cavalier ne vienne lui même hb 5 et les
blancs qui peuvent être essayé de le
fixer espions et où il faut deux
cavaliers pros h5 il fait pousser 4 est
aussi une idée très décente
il veut venir contre la casse des 5 il
faut prendre qu'adam eux deux se passe à
quelqu'un qui me confierait dans le chat
mais vu la vitesse de jeu
tout ça me semble pouvoir être proche
d'un d'une position théorique en tout
cas ce qui est intéressant c'est que sur
foot pro f 5 paires hors cac valeo 3
cavaliers des 5 et j'aime beaucoup ce
que fait notre amie sevian parce que
genre ce genre de position je vais
montrer vite fait pour qu'on puisse voir
avec un pion plus pour les noirs alors
j'ai mis une position à la va vite un un
pion d'options plus pour les noirs mais
le fou de cases blanches qui est
beaucoup trop fort ici et les blancs qui
devrait avoir un avantage entame ses
qu'adam c8 qui va arriver
bon il ya encore ça défend encore pour
les noirs un tour h f 1 en attaque ici
en gros le fou de cases noires sert à
rien et les pions font double emploi
donc c'est une excellente position pour
les blancs 5 et cavaliers de 300 prend
aux fèves 5
et surtout ici c'est ta meuf 3 d'un
principe si ce qui va arriver menace la
tour ici à peut-être d'amd 8 qui défend
la maison tiendrait le pion f6 et la
torah 8 giffa j'avais intuitivement
j'avais envie de faire de la f3 en
premier mais bon ça changerait pas grand
chose
ouais même des huit après il faut
calculer toutes les pièces noires
seraient sur la huitième grand que si
très logique dame prend ici c'est
peut-être tout rage 6 qui couvrira le
pion aux six intéressant tout ça
tmg 5
et tous rage sept et il va vouloir
repartir avec toutes ces pièces allèles
dame est peut-être contre-attaqué
quoique on va voir pour ses sets il va
vouloir pousser au centre positionné
vraiment très complexe pour moi est ce
que prend le cas le plus en plus un
clash 4 est pas possible et prendre h 4
et envoyer les pions avec les blancs
mais surprise hk tu auras le cavalier
trois kits qui traînera dont kg 4 et
peut-être manqué il prend 1,5 qui va
arriver
tam ccist tous rêvent deux tours d2 qui
est prend 1,5
autour des deux d'ailleurs défendre le
pion et après c'est de gagner ce match 4
et pouvoir envoyer la marée position est
réellement complexe les noirs mc cette
masse de pions centraux kisses avançant
des cinq et quatre avec le fou sur 15
mois pourrait contrôler un tas de cases
importante au centre et les blancs et
pas forcément le temps de contre
attaquer aussi cette idée de faire à 5 à
4 à 3 il faut comme au quai des cinq pas
jouable encore fait tour 17
les blindes bien et les blancs qui
prennent h4 comme prévieux et les noirs
qui envoie le 4k relief 6 donc il veut
pas laisser ce fou en vie et maintenant
que trois intermédiaires
ça c'est du fil rouge à tout craché le
psycho intermédiaires qui fait mal tout
rêve c'est tempo le cavalier qui a plu
énormément de cases c'est très bien joué
de la part de fear ou qu'il a vient
d'enchaîner des coûts qui faisait mal
eux trois tours et vii c'est une grosse
combine combinaison de cours est-ce que
tour f1 est possible j'aimerais même pas
y penser parce que ça vient coûts et le
cavalier ici le cavalier recul
c'est ce qui fait un an le fou à venir
en eux cinq surtout reprendre 3 y aura
du tarn pranger 2 ça va ou non et a même
dame prend ces deux il ya tous rêvent de
qui peut rodez il ya le cavalier qui est
mal placée la virunga qui est en train
de faire une démonstration d'alger 4
il n'y a pas vraiment de menaces blanche
et mercure en d5 cavalli g3 y revient
avec le cavale qui est peut-être à 5 à 4
maintenant à 3 envoyons ce pion là-bas
en éclaireur que s'il tue arrivant à 3
il y aura des maths de partout tour f2
qui veut mettre la pression sur le pion
c'est the bien évidemment tour d2 et
peut-être à 5 maintenant
il fait des qu'adam g 6 couvre la case
d3 où pranger trois âgés d'un projet de
iliad à me prendre 6 il a dû tout
calculer et il ya plus d'échecs ans et
terrifiant et les blancs qui est noir tu
as tout reprend 2 d'am-dam g4 défend
dames cécile revient pour menacer le
pion c est maintenant des trois prises
et dames c3 mais est ce que c'était
vraiment gagnant histoire j'en sais rien
c'était hyper tactique mais les noirs
les noirs ont multiplié les menaces et
ont fini par l'emporter autant défi
round jackie redoutable dans ses
positions ultra tactique
alors on a ça a transposé dans quoi ça
se trouve dans une anglaise symétrique
je crois bien
mais c'est un gris gasparotto crasse
ouais parce qu'on est un recueil
froissart ans était retournée dans une
anglaise symétrique du coup avec c4 c5
cavalière trois cavaliers f6 d4 et du
coup se combinent jamais vu honnêtement
qu'est ce que ça vaut mathieu toi qui es
dans le tchat
peux-tu nous éclairer de ta lanterne
théorique intéressant tu as joué des
années donc tueur hier qu'il va y avoir
du jeu pour pour les noirs en tout cas
ça a l'air d'être une ouverture
intéressante pour le beats
manqué qui a trois fous g4 il s'en prend
plein de voeux virtuelles manque pour le
moment quand même les blancs qui donne
l'impression de s'organiser et peut-être
il réussit à faire flouer 3 est en
réalité on va avoir l'impression
que
on va avoir l'impression que les noirs
ont pas du tout je l'a quand même j'ai
pas trop ce qui s'est passé mais les
pièces blanches qui semble s'être
organisés maintenant de façon cohérente
et je vois pas les joies que je vois pas
le quoique ya pions des cinq peut-être
qui peut se faire récupérer
j'ai quand même l'impression que les
blancs se sont quand même très bien
organisés maintenant
et qui a eu un raté de la part des noirs
alors qu'havas news5 propose des changes
des cavaliers parce qu'un coup comme dam
des cas très jouable ici et prend 15.5
fou des quatre français trois fours
prend tout reprend des 5es dame b 3 mai
à lyon 2-2 qui traîne il veut faire foi
il veut faire fou prend f6 gf
il faut prendre non et tour est fait un
fou prend le cas tout est ok et le roi
noir va être un peu faible
c'est donc ça l'idée surtout profs
devraient donc les blancs ont pris
davantage la ski alpin leucate qui est
mal
il ya le pion bessette qui a attaqué et
ya la paire de fouet cloud c3 qui est
très fort donc si rogers et est en train
de produire son accélération dans le
match il a déjà deux points de plus il
va peut-être pouvoir passer à 3 ce qui
ferait bien évidemment très mal à son
adversaire du jour
samse vian qui pourrait après avoir un
prendre un petit coup au moral qui prend
le pion bessette
il prend le pion aux deux tours f1 va
être jouée food et 3 probablement
comment la gagne la partie d'avant
sireau déjà autant tout vêtement tout
bêtement autant c'est aussi simple que
ça
c'est aussi simple que ça elle a juste
gagné autant
bien cadré après la famille de fous en
d3 il ya fait fois-ci s'il attaque la
dame prise à six reprises à cette prise
à cette prise ici auquel a décidé de
rentrer dans cette finale
considérant qu'ils avaient assez
d'activité attention tout de même dans
certainement de la tour peuvent venir en
f4 ouais non ça doit aller quand même
fait voir tour cette tour ses sept tours
b 2 tours cet arrêt on n'a pas le temps
de faire tourner des tours et y fit
huras est à wayne on s'est péniblement
qu'un temps avec les noirs j'avais pas
vu ça de base comme ça mais les blancs
un temps d'avancé
ils réussissent à doubler en premier
mais ça c'est un peu la mauvaise
nouvelle sa double en premier donc tour
prend b2 tour sept tours et futurs
points à 7
j'ai cinq élèves avoir à 4 qui va
envoyer et peut-être une idée un moment
donné avec un roi qui peut monter s'est
tendu de 3 g ii roi là
pour la tour qui va venir en a deux est
ce que les blancs ont vraiment réussir à
progresser voilà surtout pas f 6 passes
qui à tour j'ai sept matches du coup
tout raciste échec peut être une idée
mais il aura juste roi g7 qui s'activent
qu'elle va refaire tour ses sept tours
g8 à 5 mais les noirs parce qu'ils
peuvent juste attendre ont surtout pas
enlever la tour puisque [ __ ] g7 tourage
sait-on g7 maths mais f 3,3 tour à tour
f4 bonjour un 4 le retour et c'est tour
à sept qui arrive pas à partir sarah
tenir pour ses biens
belle défense ce constat ce qui nous a
caché le temps équivalent du purgatoire
en tête retour à deux et peut-être 3 6 3
roy g6 maintenant pour éviter que le roi
vienne bond façon il fait des échecs si
le roi s'approche trop on gagnera le
pion aux quais leroy qui vient à eux
quatre
donc il a laissé passer le roi c'est
pour ça que vous le mettre à tour en a
deux en fait c'était pour empêcher
justement cette idée là mais peut-être
ce n'était pas faisable
donc il va récupérer un deuxième pion
non c'est un peu chaud les mecs c'est un
peu chaud comme parti au fc séville ont
qui gagne incroyable je n'avais plus vu
le temps à tout le monde a oublié le
temps incroyable si round jackie est
tombé incroyable incroyable
c'est fou ça la finale était tellement
prenante ça allait d'un côté de l'autre
on savait pas trop ce qui se passait et
c'est perdu autant pour firoud assez
étonnant ça quand même assez que c'est
exactement ce qui m'est arrivé dimanche
vous vous rappelez bien position aussi
un peu compliqué calculer une variante
de variantes trois variantes et j'avais
oublié le temps un petit peu comme vient
de le faire fuir ou déjà ici et du coup
on peut se demander s'il n'aurait pas
mieux fait de prendre rond flex qui te
donne quand même le conseil très
important de jouer vite appris trop tant
il est tombé donc à la petite finale de
la berlinoise
donc ça va jouer cette finale irujo et
iraniens donc avec la nationalité et la
tour e 8 alors qu'est ce qu'il veut
faire avec ses pions parce que sur fouet
f4f au prince 5 et sur f6 et puis on
prend puis on prend un tour e6 peut-être
donc toujours un ces finales de la
berlinoise on a quatre pions d'un côté
mais avec des pions double est donc
c'est beaucoup plus difficile a poussé
un c'est difficile d'être un pion passé
dans une majorité leurs cadets lorsqu'il
y à part non des pions doubler les
blancs qui ont l'avantagé une majorité
propre mais d'un autre côté les blancs
qui ont du coup le pion de cinq là qui
étaient faibles et les noirs à la paire
de fou et donc les blancs qui ont donné
un pion art space était volontaire parce
qu'il a réfléchi assez longtemps après
tours 8
mais qui a un peu d'activité cependant
on voit ces huit baies 6 3 b 7 ou 8
semble être un plan possible
cette fouille 8 ici intermédiare roi
bessette qui peut arriver à tout moment
fait j'ai ici si menaces puis on prend
qui comprend fou prend f 5 1 et sur fion
prend il va reprendre de f mettra la
tour en f7 il contrôlera la case des
huit il bougera le fou et roye b 7 et 6
rouges à qui va avoir son pion de plus
tranquille et je trouve que c'est un peu
dommage de la part de ces viandes de
faire un cadeau comme ça c'est un peu
comme au tennis
vous obtenez une balle de break après à
30 partout après un superbe échange vous
êtes à 30 40 sur le service adverse il
vous sert une première balle pas très
puissante et au lieu de rentrer dans
l'échangé de mettre une belle balle
longue vous tentez vous avoue craquer
complètement et vous mettez une balle de
mer dans le filet c'est un peu ce que
vient de faire c'est viens ici dans
couverture il vient de mettre une balle
dans le filet tout bêtement
il ya même tourer d'ailleurs ici et
chacun que j'avais pas mentionné qui
peut aussi être une option pour se
débarrasser d'une tour ou une bête
double faute alors là sur x fuite qu'est
ce qui se passe à tour un échec
justement
alors là c'est bien c'est vraiment la
double faute et c'est très dommage en
cuir ou déjà s'inspire de notre ami
hikaru nakamura en buvant une canette de
red bull assémian c'est quand même
triste de perdre comme ça la partie avec
les plantes qui plus est c'est un gros
cadeau c'est un très très gros cadeau
réalisé par le joueur iranien par le
joueur américain pardon
on peut même jouer vous aussi c est roi
bessette
n'y a aucun problème ici pour les noirs
qui ont de plus en plus maintenant avec
une structure un petit peu sale avec
beaucoup de qui ont doublé mais à la
paire de four ça devrait pouvoir pouvoir
y aller les mecs je sais pas ce que vous
en pensez dans le chat mais ça devrait
pouvoir gagner alors il fait fait quatre
il veut jouer fouet f5 maximaliste
ferroudja fois fit marche toujours pas à
cause de tour en échec bien évidemment
mais le score est toujours de plus 1 en
faveur de l'iranien c'est bien là ce
n'est même pas à quoi joue et je vais
dégoûté de son jeu quel cadeau quel
cadeau quel dommage ludique si ça
s'abandonne quasiment
savant donne quasiment c'est désespérant
mais bon il vient de gagner la
précédente autant il a raison d'un
pelage ou et qui sait
mais c'est en train de s'empirer coup
après coup
la tour qui va arriver trois finit par
échanger peut-être fois h4 ici pour vous
prend h 3o foulant avec exactement la
même idée et abandon de ces vian qui
paye cher son erreur dans l'ouverture
mais c'est difficile vraiment difficile
pour le joueur le joueur américain
alors c'est bien qu'ils que tous les
conseils qu'on lui a donné non non vous
n'avez aucun des conseils qu'on lui a
donnée avec ses problèmes de zeit note
ne l'ont aidé du coup j'ai envie de dire
c'est un bel hommage à ses coachs donc
la partie qui est en train de se
dérouler de nouveau cette anglaise
symétrique cette fois ci avec un eto'o
de ma roxy un petit peu comme dans une
sicilienne quelque part sauf qu'il y
avait six foulées 7
mais ça pourrait on pourrait retomber
dans une structure de type hérisson
donc
non quand donc pour ces 8
on nous propose dans le chat de faire
flouer trois tons c1
ce qui paraît logique mais fois f4
peut-être pas mal il veut prendre le
contrôle de la case des six - chacun
peut-être dam des deux tours d un
qui est pour 5 et des deux protège le
pion ça allait dans tous les sens
pas évident comme position et g5 pour
s'emparer de la case de 5 pour le
cavalier quoi ces thématiques de la part
des noirs pour gagner un petit peu
d'espacé gagner une case et 20 ans il
fait qu'ils agissent ici va mettre ce
cavalier dans le cinq et suit la f4
éventuellement ça peut nous rappeler des
belles parties de maxime ça les cars et
les qui viennent danser près du roi
beaucoup d'activités pour les noirs le
cahier qui vient aux cinq qui revient en
17 quand même parce que c'est fatah
quelqu'un b6 il va quand même falloir
faire quelque chose de tout ça h saint
calais il en voit assez bien peut-être
dameuse d'un f2 pour les blancs les
noirs qui chasse le cavalier a quatre
qui ont peut-être revenir et 15
cavaliers sur cinq
la mef de tourbe et 8 donc on couvre
bien le pion pays si si si et de calais
b 3 qui vient vers la case des cats pour
s'en prendre aux fous comment est ce que
les noirs vont continuer leur attaque
ici on va le voir très bientôt
ce qu'ils vont jouer un truc comme h4
est 5h 3% prendre vraiment aux cases
blanches et joue avec ce fou est-ce que
ça a plutôt avec du cavalier f4 commence
par dame 8 il s l'option b 600 prises et
il fait g4 donc en question c'est
qu'est-ce qu'il a préparé sur f4 il
voulait probablement quartier pour un f4
dame prenait 4 pourpre en b 6
donc elle a échangé une fois et remet la
tour ans amy timm menace le pion c4 moi
j'aime beaucoup les noirs ici
en tout cas on glisse je trouve que
c'est très dangereux la tour le fou le
cavalier tous a atteint 15,3 et le roi
derrière j'adore les noirs des fourrages
quatre des 17 intermédiaire un jour
attention tout cas la position est très
complexe
il ya des pièces emprise de partout ces
lacs firoud déjà excellent la dame qui
vit en décati avec trois ans prise mais
peut-être souhaitent ils jouaient 17
intermédiaire pour aller rechercher une
dame c'est possible tout est possible
après un petit coup comme d'amd c'est
peut-être dans adam 17 pays ces cinq et
tout reprend ses 5es à prévenir prendre
en f3 mais je sais pas ce que ça vaut
c'était un peu con de donner autant de
matériel bon alors là j'ai envie de dire
messieurs bon courage pour calculer mais
est ce que les noirs ont vraiment autant
d' attaque qu'il ne semble tout rêve
c'est un coup très tranquille qui vient
contrôler la case 17 et menacé le x 7
donc le fou qui en b 6
enfin il était celui menacé un parce
qu'ils étaient protégés par la dame est
maintenant peut-être est franc e cat way
et foued de très bien joué de la part de
ces vian
elle est ce qu'on peut tenter un dame f8
pour venir vers f3 tackels cavaliers
éventuellement il fait un bref cette fou
ici h4 c'est hyper complexe comme
position qu'est-ce qu'on a
matériellement on a une dame et de
l'autre côté on a quoi on a un cavalli
un un cavalier une tour et roux deux
pions donc en fait l'avantagé matériel
et pour les blancs mais le roi est pas
terrible dame f2 avec l'idée de jouer
cavalier g4
17 menace de faire dame va fort mètres
la tour en des huit ya pas trop le choix
et sur quelle promo 6 peut-être carrier
g4 et on m'attend premier avec les noirs
donc feu de empêche cavaler g4 et
maintenant peut-être cavaliers f3 fou
prend dame prend epyon h trois meilleurs
atours d2 encore j'en sais rien les mecs
c'est hyper complexe
de toute façon faut prendre f3 et forcé
ah non il ya tour j'ai un échec
intermediary devait y avoir un match sur
foued 3 qui écumait qui m'a échappée qui
vient avec laurent à schwyz adam un
échec arrêt dame france et 3 les noirs
qui ont récupéré toutes les pièces les
blancs qui veulent quand même encore
jouer parce qu'il ya encore ce pion 17
qui est dangereux alors maintenant est
ce que les noirs peuvent réussir à faire
un petit coup de billard pour récupérer
la tourache 4
dam des deux rois juste 3 bien
évidemment dame e3 voilà les dames g5
mayroy je crois le retour attention de
pas faire perpète fou prend le cas de
bien jouer cavalier prend le cadre d'un
projet 4 et aura tout reprendre 17 et
les noirs ont une dame net de plus et
une nouvelle fois sévillans qui revient
à 1 point et 1 et 1,5 sévillans qui est
vraiment impressionnant au moment où on
pense que le joueur américain a
finalement cédé et que l'arménien a pris
le dessus dans le match l'américain
répond immédiatement immédiat mal avec
une victoire de belle facture
donc le joueur américain qui se laissent
pas qui se laisse pas mourir
il reste dans le match ils recollent à
chaque fois au score
est-ce qu'il va réussir à rééditer cette
performance tout au long du match
ça on ne peut pas encore le savoir mais
ce qui est sûr et certain c'est que le
joueur américain ne va pas se laisser
mourir et va tout donner pour revenir et
recoller 1 c'est sa ble ment au score un
peu comme dans le tour de france
lorsqu un couard s'échappe et qu'un
juste derrière qui veut pas lâcher qui
reste dans la roue t-shirt ouvert qui
cherchent ils cherchent à apprendre de
l'oxygène et il y arrive on a simplement
donc cette fois-ci sévillans qui a
réussi à mettre les deux pions avec 5
500 vérifier parce que jamais non c'est
pas c'est pas moi qui sonne je me méfie
maintenant il a réussi à mettre les
pions f5 et aux 500 se les faire manger
et cette fois ci c'est peut-être lui qui
est mieux parce qu'il a la même position
tout à l'heure sauf qu'il a réussi avec
ses pions centraux à contrôler du coup
un but qu'ils sont tous les deux rester
en vie c'est les fous noir qui sont
complètement maîtrisé mal à un
rassemblement c'est un mot qui existe un
les mecs vous pouvez aller chercher dans
le dictionnaire sans se lasser
en fait quand même très très attention
et donc avoir à 3
alors comment est ce que les blancs pour
progresser cette majorité a les droits
gerin c'est simplement ça va je parle
pendant 3 heures 30 non-stop tout seul
les mecs donc commencé par me parlait
poliment déjà un qui met le pion f6 et
on voit qu'il a bien progressé bien
comme il faut et peut-être un cavalier
qui va arriver angers 5 voire même
cavalier prend ses cinq ici vu que le
fou est reparti en des 8 et cette fois
ci c'est sam sévillans qui a réussi à
gagner un pion dans cette berlinoise et
il faut dire que le roi noir a du mal à
s'activer fin à relier ces tours les
pièces voire en pls total et maintenant
il va y avoir du tour f 5 tours h5 tout
reproche 4 dans les blancs sont vraiment
très bien
re 4 et peut-être juste un petit coup de
tours en 1 pour clouer voilà c'est chose
faite
position qui semble quasi désespérée
pour les noirs et ce sera intéressant de
voir le joueur américain recoller à 7
partout un peu plus de alors ils sont à
dépasser la moitié du match si on compte
1 que la moitié du match et quand il
reste trente minutes de 3 + 1 on est un
peu un peu voilà c'est la partie on la
partie précédente à mi match on était à
7,6 pour fear ou dja est donc là on
avance dans le match et c'est evian qui
pourraient recoller ici un tout et il
est pas mal et ce que fit route j'avais
pas en train de tilter et tous rêvent
carette voilà là il devait y a plus fou
prend des trois fours en f1 pour essayer
de sauver un peu les meubles fou b6
échec à y avoir watch de wan'an paroisse
âge de mayroy f3 quelque part et ça
aurait gagné alors attention qu est ce
qui vient de se passer
ok on a quitté la partie pour un très
court instant et donc on en est où dans
ce match on en est à 7 partout 25
minutes de jeu
égalité parfaite ferroudja qui a gagné
donc la cession en 5 + 1 sur le score de
5-4 et ma samse vian qui mène la section
2 3 + 1 sur le score de 3 à 2 donc
l'égalité est parfaite je rappelle qu'en
fin de match en cas en cas de match nul
il y aura quatre parties en 1 + 1 pour
décider du sort du match
donc une nouvelle espagnols qui ont
contrôle du centre ça me fait bien
qu'ils jouent ces petites variantes avec
le fj enquête auger 6 ou g7 et on va
voir ce que ça va donner alors cavaliers
à 5 peut-être pour attaquer le foufou à
deux et je vous disais tout à l'heure il
avait joué comme en juin et terrasse on
peut jouer avec ses 5 par la suite pour
essayer de jouer ces quatre oui
peut-être que la défaite autant un
peut-il t'es fier round joie même s'il a
réussi à en apprendre un cadeau tout à
l'heure il y avait eu un des cinq
maintenant peut-être que lecavalier
pourrait repartir directement vers des
huit voire même vers sète
je m'attends pas à voir un dessin qui si
les deux joueurs qui qui se placent pour
l'instant toujours plus agréable à jouer
avec les blancs puisque on a les pions
des 4 et 4 bien installé au centre mais
rien n'est fait bien évidemment dans
cette partie
est-ce que je peux expliquer la
différence s'explique chasser les
déchets classiques c'est la cadence en
fait en échec la cie qui a on va dire en
moyenne deux heures trente pour chaque
joueur pour la partie et dans les dents
les speech est dans les échecs rapide y
a que 5 minutes par partie ou trois où
une minute donc c'est surtout le temps
de réflexion qui est différent speech
elles sont plus rapides
on voit plus de jeux hors des cinq
cavaliers e set peut-être ici
mais bon ça rique le pion c'est certes
un peu faible
et cet ours et 8 pour défendre mais les
blancs quand même un avantage des
espaces certains quidam des trois tours
à huit tours c'est un hutu race est un
lait petit à petit les blancs qui vont
mettre la pression sur le pion c7 le
pion à 6 on essaie peut-être de triplés
même sur cette colonne peut y avoir du
h4 et h5 aussi un jour pour affaiblir f5
là c'est vrai que les noirs semblent
semble bien bloqué mes joues caïds et
celle qui veut peut-être essayer de
jouer pour f5 alors est ce que les noirs
ont joué foulée blanche pousser dota
jouée ces six pour s'activer
allez je pense faut envoyer à 5,6 peut
essayer de s'activer avec les noirs dont
kelly le prêt par le roi qui était pas
forcément en place pour ce plan là c'est
vrai françois rey que les noirs sont
sacrément visser
peut-être car les b 6
ok ça je suis pas sûr
soins et s'y intéresser que ça d'avoir
échangé ce fou je suis un peu étonné
parce que le foot et c'est ce fait quand
même pas grand chose et donner la quatre
fins et la casse des cinq finalement et
du coup sa axa couvert le pion c7 des
noirs aussi donc ce cet échange là de
faire passer le pion des hans et 6 et un
peu bizarre y'a pas de cavalier qui peut
arriver en dessins qu'ils ne sont que
même le coup avec 5 sera d'autant plus
fort ici pour les noirs donc je suis un
petit peu étonnés du choix de fil rouge
à damerey dames 8 c'est même lui qui
devient une cible et maintenant même les
dessins qui sont envisageables pour les
noirs d'ailleurs peut-être par un an
passe captée du fou prend b6 et tout ça
mais
bon c'est pas encore si facile ok il
fait passer depuis 1 4h quatre peut-être
f5 ici n'ont pas encore cédé 1,8 que
j'ai pas trop aimé j'aurais aimé jouer
pour f5 en fait là celle qui manque la
dame maintenant
ça donnait envie mais ok cavaliers l'a
peut-être que faire cavale et ses huit
cavaliers eu cette intention abc skyn
qui traînera
réaliser des blancs d'année le cavalier
en c4 il avait pas forcément vu c'est
bien cette idée là ont ils à temps pour
le moment mais c'est vrai que c'est pas
folichon folichon touche à rien mais à
force de touche à rien ils laissent les
blancs s'organiser à m6 le fou enfermé
alors il n'a pas pris puisque
équilibrant c'est cet intermédiaire qui
était très fort et qui donne et options
passé lié très bien joué de la part de
filles route jamais maintenant les noirs
qui contre attaque allait droit et ça
pourrait partir après un échange avec
des tours qui viendrait sur la colonne
jay pour aller mater la position est
très complexe ici difficile de dire qui
va l'emporter
les blancs plus que 26 secondes
ferroudja qui va devoir faire mieux que
la dernière fois
alors il envoie le pion qui est prend
des 5
il envoie bessette maintenant j'imagine
les vents vont enlever le cavalier voilà
c'est chose faite
laisser prendre à 8 reprend de la tour
joue avec la qualité de moins mais
maintenant il faut peut-être faire
flouer six dames 7 g 5
il fait des cinq faut trouver du contre
jeu ici pour les noirs américains
ralliés arrive en 4 la firme jam a l'air
très bien la tour carrée mambé cette
cavalière cinq dames c4 j'ai
l'impression que les noirs sont
complètement ficelé très mal autant la
tour qui vient en d1 raya du cloud âge
de partout les pièces noires sont
complètement aux abois place apparaît
impossible de remonter ça
le fou qui y en a eu sept and carry qui
attaque et cavaliers 3 quelle défense
pour le moment du joueur américain qui
reste en vie dans cette partie qui
récupère h4 ou jolie cavalière 6le à ce
tour h7 maths et surtout rejet cette
tourbe et huit tours g8 maths contre
attaque de fil rouge à qui l'emportent
et qui reprend les devants dans ce match
et c'est bien qu'il ya peut-être pas été
assez entreprenant un moment donné qu'on
y lira avec vous ses six têtes il
fallait envoyer du jeu en voyant des
cinq ans voyant f5
il a quand même beaucoup attendu et
salua pas ça lui a pas souri
soit 6 a pas eu le h5 de tout à l'heure
de la part de fuir ou déjà et on est
toujours dans cette position qui sort
d'un joueur de chez venin gh avec ses
pions doublé ce roi noir qui peut venir
là qui peut faire du grand roque
il donne le pion à 6 ils bougent le roi
et il va venir attaquer devant de son
roi donc c'est très intéressant il fut
très bien cette variante firoud déjà
c'est son jeu c'est son style firoud qui
est vraiment a vraiment un joueur
redoutable jeu le voir iraniens à qui il
est promis à un avenir doré à l'or des
cinq là il ya six ans prise mais ils
s'en fichent complètement il veut juste
se servir de ça pour te faire tours à
huit dames à cinq je peux montrer
vraiment un genre d'idées avec la tour
qui arrivant à 8
la dame qui arrivant à 5 et le pion qui
est très dur à défendre donc c'est juste
une idée parmi d'autres un que j'essaye
de vous montrer en avance rapide donc il
a pris en dessin qui fait tout revin et
maintenant les noirs vous êtes souffert
tout retour des 6 3 autour des 8 ou l'aï
laférois b 8 12 heures qui se prendra
jamais de vous prend à 6 échecs et veut
peut-être envoyer aussi plus tard le
pion à vera 3 pour aller attaquer les
cases au rugby on pas que les blancs
n'ont pas de fous de cases noires donc
s'il est noir réussissent à toucher les
cases noires ça pourrait faire très très
mal
pour sam sévillan il reste plus que 15
minutes maintenant dans le 3 + 1 le
match qui avance qui avance qui avance
et firent ouja qui quand même malgré la
belle résistance de ces vian semblent
contrôler ce match donc
tours d2
à 5km série fraîche sur la page que j'ai
un petit bug non
ok bon ok à 5 c'est bien ce que je
disais j'ai les jeux la taille de
l'écran qui s'était changé
enfin que je fasse gaffe donc à cinq qui
veut jouer avec à 4 à 3
alors qu'est ce que vont faire les
blancs ici comment empêcher ça g4 j'ai
l'impression que c'est tellement lent
côté blanc alors rendez-vous peut-être
cavaliers pro f 6 et surtour des six
savoir g5
mais bon les noirs peuvent être ignorés
et faire un 4 à 3
ok tour des six ans et 8 et a4 a3
rennais ça moi ça me paraît tellement
bien pour les noirs il ajoute elle ment
bien ses positions firoud déjà le roi
blanc qui me paraît vraiment être dans
le dur
je vous le dis je vous le dis comme ça
mais le roi blanc paraît mal on ne sait
pas le cadre peut-être y avait quatre au
ciré mais la tour des dieux protégé par
la dame dont il y aura pas de vous prend
à deux tons des six tours des 8
c'est un plan qu'on avait évoqué tout à
l'heure 23
dams et si ce qui est peut-être car a
lieu quatre du vous fournir colmater un
peu cette case s'est bien défendue
sevian mais à quel prix il lui reste
plus que dix secondes
salut à bosse dans le tchat
à quel prix leur exil seconde contre une
minute trente
et ça paraît vraiment compliquée pour le
joueur américain de défendre ça avec si
peu de temps phil rogers va trouver un
truc là d un fois qu'il avait défendu
avec si peu de temps une position
similaire il est défini par tomber donc
le pion qui arrive en a trois détroit
est maintenant si une dame arrive en c3
c'est la catastrophe
mais surtout pour eux quatre ils font
preuve 4 el allam couvrirait la case c3
donc pour le moment ça tient encore pour
les noirs je vais avoir trouvé un autre
plan pour réussir à passer la muraille
athènes
peut-être qu'il va mettre la dame en
baisse 5 ou en cessant b5 pour défendre
un peu tout en c7 aussi bien placé et
ses trois jouets fous ces cinq dames f3
hockey / pions premier peut-être prendre
même de la dame est allée chercher des
échanges plus que quatre secondes pour
sévillan et on a encore 30 pour fuir ou
de jacky fait tour d un tour c'est 2 to
defend dreux la tour qui peut venir en
d2 ça paraît tellement dangereux il ya
tellement plus de cases noires pour les
blancs b prend ses trois tours france et
3 il veut peut-être mettre la dame en c2
dans les robinets donc la foulée katia
matin la tour en c1
et s'il va réussir à mettre la dame en
c2 et peut-être essayer de jouer un jour
avec eux pour le contre hockey fih route
jacky échange encore des pièces et il
veut partir avec son roi mais ok y'a
d'amd cet échec ici à la position est
complètement nul
alors le fair-play voudrait là quand
même faire nul can dance et speechless
juniors jusqu'à maintenant on a eu un
comportement très fair play de la part
des joueurs
là en plus c'est une seconde parcours
seyant qui gagne un pion mais il va pas
pouvoir faire mieux
son pion plus peut pas avancer et donc
ça va faire nul dès lors il faut tenter
serouart 4 et ferb et quatre échecs
qui faut quand même qu'il fasse gaffe
fouet de passe prendre un il peut faire
trois des cinq rois ici roi des 6,3 b2
et b4 hockey faire juste croire ses 5es
des quatre échecs peut-être non je
pensais qu'ils allaient risquer vegas
jacques roy prendra des cinq mais bon ça
sert à rien mais juste pour un jour un
peu plus longtemps
j'ai donc assez bien ce que je pensais
ça me des cadres à la deuxième fille
round jackie est mort de rire
il était c'est vrai pas loin de là
gagner et donc on est reparti toujours
avantage au score pour le joueur iranien
et il reste neuf minutes aux caisses
deux parties là clairement non il en est
roi il en est celle là la suivante est
une terre hier il reste trois parties en
trois plus un les mecs c'est quasi sûr
parce que cette partie là devrait pas
durer neuf minutes ça paraît quand même
quasi impossible en 3 + 1 et donc si
round jackie vavrek qui tournera à
minima égalité à mon avis hein je le
vois pas perdre trois parties d'affilée
la hm3 +1 et on va attaquer après les
bulles est où le joueur iranien semble
être le plus avantagé mais bon
donc cette finale elle vaut quoi c'est
de nouveau une finale avec des pions
doublé d'un côté mais les noirs qui ont
ici à un avantage quand même de
développement on peut peut-être faire un
truc avec grand roque et f5 peut-être
pour bien ouvrir le jeu comme il faut
essayer de profiter des pièces blanches
qui semble pas très bien organisé pour
le moment surtout quand on est le pion à
f/5 on enlève le pion f7 du trip et
comme le roi est venu à eux deux avec
alice et 6 quand même plus logique on
veut venir en d4 pour recoller à un
échec
le roi qui va venir en f1 est maintenant
peut-être des quatre cavaliers des cinq
noms des quatre cadets 5 kw est donc
peut-être j'allais dire tour 8 f-35
peut-être quelque chose comme ça mais
j'ai l'impression que le roi blanc va
réussir à aller se cacher et après vous
grattez les changements mais je sais pas
j'étais en train de ouais il semble que
tu vois c'est au moment où je regardais
pas où j'étais en train de regarder un
peu mes trucs
exactement j'étais en train de regarder
j'ai un peu raté ça arrive que le rap un
ou deux coups ce qu'elles se prêtent
d'échiquier c'était des cadres est donc
allé noir qui ont bénéficié de ce prêt
move à un peu hâtif et pas utile mais
dont qui ont ce léger avantage sans que
ce soit vraiment non plus un
rédhibitoire donc vous avez les dates
aujourd'hui c'était 18 heures le match
demain 17 heures le 11 juillet 18h de
nouveau avec un autre choc maqsoud loup
contre sarah n'a donc il sera un match
très intéressant à suivre et le dernier
match des onglets duras qui me semble
personnellement déséquilibré je vais
être exigeant quand même grand favori du
match numéro quatre mais tout ça ce sera
à suivre dans les prochains jours donc
vous ces six protège le pion après la
position doit être égale ici quand même
les noirs - peu d'activité mais d'un
autre côté les blancs une meilleure
structure de pions ils ont réussi à
stabiliser la position
donc ya pas de raison qu'ils aient un
avantage quelconque pour les noirs ici
faut pas exagérer c'est juste un petit
truc insipide
la perdrix dans le tableau que les
quatre joueurs de gauche vont gagner
possible possible ils sont favoris en
tout cas mais sarah may peut surprendre
magouilles où sont donc les blancs qui
laisse le pion c4 mais ça créerait des
pions triplet c'est pas c'est pas un
problème c'est pas tabou
on peut peut-être faire un coup comme
tourbe et 8 pour essayer de profiter
d'un semis pions arriérés mais le truc
c'est que trois pions sur une même
colonne c'est pas très impressionnant ça
sert pas forcément à grand chose c'est
peut-être même les blancs qui vont se
retrouver nu un jour parce que j'ai
l'impression que là ça progresse pas
trop et si les blancs a eu six envoyés
leurs pions je ne vois pas pourquoi ce
ne serait pas le joueur iranien qui
aurait un léger avantage ici même au
québec faire à 5 à 4 et sûr à trois rois
b3
on comprend ce qu'il veut jouer donc là
surtout pas tout reprendre ici saint
parce qu'après c'est prend du coup les
pions serait très fort mais revin pour
défendre c'est bien joué à quatre il
veut faire à 3 donc à trois échecs et
sur ab3 il y avait un élégant je vais
montrer ça il y avait un élégant
cavaliers c'est un match assez joli donc
avec 1 3 il a réussi à chasser droit et
maintenance et les blancs qui sont mieux
puisque les noirs ont plus du tout de
jeu allèles dames c'est fini et les
blancs vont pouvoir essayer de faire
tour sept tours 5 et venir capitaliser
sur leur majorité allait droit vous
voyez cette majorité ce 4 contre 2 est
complètement noir le roi s'est fait
chasser il sert plus à rien et
maintenant c'est les blancs qui vont
venir titiller les pions cavaliers de
tourcoing f4 par exemple peut être une
vraie idée pour les blancs
après avoir un pass prendre un sale truc
avec toujours des deux croix ou quoi
j'ai fait tous réfutent attention je ne
peux pas partir la ja cavaliers b5 et ci
par là et la tour f 7 égale qu'ils ont
accès tous et 7 qui va tomber donc ils
vont encore gagner un pion il viendra
s'occuper de râches par la suite donc là
ça semble maintenant très difficile
après trois sets
les blancs maintenant l'équivalent de 1
gros pions plus voire même deux et ils
vont essayer d'aller en chercher un
troisième ce qui semble inéluctable
donc les noirs qui résiste encore un peu
o'kelly des cieux fait retour des 6 et
tours d2 essayer d'aller prendre le pion
là et tout rejet si si si hockey c'est
une belle résistance de la part de deux
sévillans qui a trouvé des superbes
ressources pour rentrer dans une finale
où il est toujours un peu moins bien
ou pas c'est un problème de caméra une
déconnexion de quelqu'un ok il a un pion
- toujours mais il peut échanger en
force
le cavalier cette finale nuls théorique
si manning qui a fait 3 b six mètres un
pion en c6 et ça c'est nul théorique ça
je perds un peu parce qu'à peut-être des
idées 2 à 4 à 5
donc ça va jouer encore quand même un
petit moment
attention à fuir ou déjà de pas tomber
mais si roja qui va forcément tenter sa
chance
cette finale là les pions sont pas d'une
symétrie total et donc ça peut un peu
joué allez enfin aller chercher quelque
chose
ouais c'est pas mal ce qu'il a fait avec
avec les blancs il n'y a pas de battre
cette fois ci hayatou reprend ses six
paris la mise clic a eu le mystique de
ces vian qui va coûter la partie
c'est cruel très cruel
c'est très très très cruel pour pour le
joueur américain qui a misé clic
aïe aïe aïe
et la main hier matin mais sinon le roi
venant g7 l'idée l'idée c'était de
ramener le roi
angers cet effet retour et fit pour fort
pour forcer les changer donc c'est la
dernière partie finalement du 3 + 1
puisqu'elle a duré longtemps donc deux
minutes de pause de cinq minutes de
pause et après on va passer à la
dernière séquence la séquence du 1 + 1
on se retrouve dans 5 minutes l'élite a
tout de suite
[Musique]
alors les tontons on est parti pour le
bullet qui est reparti avec un tout
petit peu d'avancé donc ce final de
bullet ça va être trente minutes de une
minute plus une minute d'une minute plus
une seconde contre 8 puis une seconde
fille route jacques un des tout
meilleurs joueurs du monde en une + 0
dois-je le répéter c'est vian qui est
pas en reste non plus et donc dans cette
première partie on a déjà une première
escarmouche tactique attention qui a été
attaquée non il n'y a pas de problème
3233 éloquent même pour fil rouge à et
3100 pour ces viandes on a affaire à
deux monstres absolu de la cadence
alors qu'est ce qui va se passer dans
cette partie à trois il s'en prend
option à 4 sur qui on prend est ce que
l'idée ce serait pas de reprendre de la
tour pour réussir à faire coulisser
cette tour sur la troisième
est ce que c'est bien on va réussir à
mettre en oeuvre une attaque sur le roi
genre foulée deux dames 1 pouvait
traîner mes cavaliers 17 vient prendre
le contrôle de la grande diagonale
alors ici après les blancs on vient de
jouer le cavalier en f1 ou est-ce qu'il
veut aller ce cavalier peut-être vers
verges et trois par la suite le fond ou
la dame est attaquée d'amd 8 peut-être
dam des deux fois ci ce qui peut arriver
dans le foot qui vient en d3 il vient
contrôler des nouvelles caresse comme la
casa 6 le fou bessette a pas trop
d'espacés aux cavaliers à cinq a
carrément lui plus de cases
les tours sont pas très actif pour les
noirs les blancs ou un grand avantage
d'espacé ici on se demande après fou des
deux peut être un moment donné où est ce
que le cavalier peut aller mais il peut
lancer six peut-être temps que pions et
en dessins qu'ils auraient pu gagner une
pièce ça n'a pas été le cas a poussé 400
prendre qui ont bougé 500 prend à la
dame
la dame qui va peut-être partir en live
cette non cavale et f6 pour protéger
peut être un coup comme tout radio web
pour faire tourner de venir s'en prendre
aux pions des six cavaliers au sein qui
s'activent prise prise tour des deux
tours qui peut venir peut-être temps 17
à un moment donné la tour c 7 qui couvre
la case 17 la dame qui vient à eux deux
peut-être tour d un qui va arriver on
échange autour des 1
il n'y a pas la case f5 pour le monde
peut-être h 4 h 5 peut arriver pour se
libérer peut-être cette case un jour
dans le cavalier qui va venir en f1 puis
yeux 3 puis j'ai qu'un tirage 5 pour les
noirs peut-être damas devrait bien jouer
il veut passer de l'autre côté peut-être
revenir vers à 5 un jour pour attaquer
aux 5 à attaquer ces sept
le cavalier qui viendraient fin il se
laisse pas prendre peut-être cavaliers
h2k vaille f3 qui arrivent pour les
blancs ici tourbe et s'il chasselas tour
la tour qui va sûrement venir vers la
case des huit noms elle revient en d3
peut-être pour du tour j'ai trois à
venir la dame qui arrive finalement on a
cinq qui menace le pion à eux cinq ici
il faut être 6 le couvre et apprend à 7
gagne le pion la tour qui part vers b4
cette dame blanche qui revient à eux
trois ça va deux partout
la dame qui revient à eux deux alors
maintenant matériel manga quoi il ya un
pion plus le cavalier qui va finir par
arriver en f3 le combat est intense le
fou qui vient b5 la tour qui n'a pas le
temps de venir en 17 grâce au cloud âge
le rouage de tourner cette menace la
tour qui revient en 18 foule sekkat
attaque le pion aux 6 est ce que le
cavalier va réussir à jaillir sur g5 1
jour où c'est le fou qui vient de super
d'être cavaliers prendre cinq ici était
jouable
on ne sait pas les blancs qui propose
les changes des dames les noirs qui
veulent échanger un f4 afin de
développer les pions les avions aussi
ses adieux 4 qui tombe cette finale
elles seraient censés être gagnante si
le roy revenait facilement en jeu mais
c'est pas si simple que ça de le ramener
le roi est mise en cage
est ce que c'est vraiment gagnant pour
les blancs g prend 1,4 g prend h 4
pouces et six fours ans et six pions
français 6 3 des 6 3 g de roy prend ses
six wife trois peut-être ça gagner
peut-être ça gagner peut-être pas mais
là malheureusement pour ces viandes il
ya le petit deux coups de fouet chèque
et il va pas réussir à l'emporter
grosse occasion ratée par le joueur
américain qui reste donc à moins 2 il
reste 26 minutes de match et c'est
toujours l'iranien qui domine attention
sévillans qui a montré les crocs dans
l'art première partie mais qui a laissé
passer une occasion vraiment très très
très importante à mon humble avis il
faudrait saisir là pour revenir dans le
match toutes les occasions firoud déjà
été sous pression mais il a défendu
comme un beau diable donc dans cette
position là on a une sicilienne avec une
position deux types hérisson le hérisson
c'est quand on a ses pions qui piquent
qui piquent typique dur les blancs qui
ont un avantage des spasmes et les noirs
qui ont aucune faiblesse les pions sont
bien pour
tg et c'est souvent une position il est
difficile d'entreprendre pour les blancs
parce que quand on avance on peut se
frotter au pic du hérisson d'où le nom
hérisson on se répète complètement mais
bon j'ai envie de dire on fait ce qu'on
peut
donc les noirs qui attendent pour le
moment on voit qui replace leur pièce le
foin à 8
le fou en c'est ça être peut-être le
pion qui va venir angers 5-1 jours le
cac va y en a eu cinq on voit les noirs
qui joue traître qui sont très compacts
et qui viennent maintenant s'amuser sur
les cases noires il va y avoir du
cavalier 5 peut-être du cavalier g6 du
cavalier f4 une tour qui pourrait
revenir ans et 8 et halcyon c4 qui
pourraient être attaqués il ya un petit
coup de f5 qui peut arriver g5
attention attention firoud déjà le
hérisson peut piquer les pièces blanches
semble bien placé mais c'est vraiment
vraiment compliqué est ce qu'un petit
coup de b5 peut arriver quand même pour
mettre un cavalier en c6 et venir
essayer d'en fermer soit huit mannequins
et des cas il prend des cinq le four
garder un petit peu cette diagonale le
fouet la dame qui attaque sur age 2 la
dame qui défend bien côté blanc pour le
moment mais on sent le danger arriver il
peut y avoir du tour du refoud prend des
cinq tours prend foudroyage de présage
de prises âge de prise de 3 à la fin on
voit les pièces noires qui peuvent
s'activer mais le cavalier qui vient au
f5
est ce que fout e5 était vraiment un bon
coup peut-être pas parce que maintenant
le cavagnan f5 défend le fou et 3 et
donc toutes les ide à bas ce fou prend
des 5 es fou prend h2 ne marche plus
parce que la dame protège le foot blanc
qui vient maintenant c'est 5 menace
peut-être un jour du cavalier cet échec
il ya un échange en d5 les blancs qui
vont probablement reprendre de la tour
puis reprendre ensuite peut-être du pion
ils peuvent aussi prendre du plomb
directement pour mettre le pion des six
fois f4 menace la tour où va partir
cette tour elle peut partir en e2 elle
peut partir
elle peut partir en e2 assez logique la
tour noire qui vient à eux cinq masters
f5 g4 chasse le cavalier à manon
lecavalier qui revient à m6 la case f4
qu'un peu faible mais c'est vrai que les
noirs n'ont plus le flou de cases
blanches pour attaquer sur cette
diagonale c'est la dame qui s'y colle du
cou qui vient maintenant peut-être un
tour problème cinq cavaliers h4 peut
donner envie pour venir donner du jeu
mais y aura toujours un fou qui viendra
en g2 pour gêner du coup le cavalier
viande et 5
il ya des pièces emprise de partout
c'est ultra tactique
les noirs qui veulent peut-être
cavaliers f4 maintenant pour attaquer la
dame mais la dame qui va pouvoir revenir
éventuellement vers rêve de fou et
quatre intermédiaires contre attaque la
dame la dame en f2 c'est ultra tactique
mais les blancs qui reste avec le pion
en d6 en plus et finalement les noirs
sont complètement vie c'est ici l'attak
le hérisson les piques du hérisson n'ont
pas réussi à piquer justement etc les
piques du pion des six qui vont piquer
peut-être un fouet f5 qui va arriver
alors pas tout de suite parce qu adam
prend ses six mais ça va finir par
rentrer à il fait tout reprendre cadre
d'un procès 6o là qu'est ce qui s'est
passé c'est aller à la vitesse de
l'éclair il ya une erreur tactique de la
part de fuir ou dja est maintenant c'est
mars et sevian qui prend le dessus et
qui a une pièce de plus mais il faut
encore réussir à la concrétiser et je
peux vous dire que c'est pas simple
parce que les pièces blanches sont bien
placés le pion des six qui est gênant ou
cavaliers f2 qui menacent attention
échec échec j'ai six cavaliers f2 qui
menace toujours le cas et qui revient f4
que c'est difficile vous prend à quatre
mains il ya le pion le cavaliere 4 qui
tombe ça encore retourner cette partie
très très complexe maintenant c'est
peut-être plus tôt les blancs qui sont
mieux quoique est ce que quelqu'un est
mieux ici
difficile à dire en tout cas le pion qui
part il va y avoir un échec perpétuel
non y'a pas mieux ni pour les blancs ni
pour les noirs ça se solde sur la nulle
dans cette partie les deux joueurs qui
se rendent vraiment coup pour coup fille
round jackie était devant ensuite
sévillans qui a eu l'occasion et qui ne
réussit pas à conclure
match nul toujours deux points d'avancé
pour firoud déjà qu'ils s'en tirent
quand même bien parce qu'il s'en tire
bien dans la partie numéro un est dans
la 2 ça semblait avoir tourné
maintenant on est dans une sicilienne
toujours un peu ce système chez venant
qu'avec le cas et qui prend b3 firoud
déjà qui va aller attaquer à fond à
l'est le roi allen dame pardon avec à 5
à 4 pendant que ces viandes va peut-être
faire du cavalier f5 on ne sait pas et
on voyait les pions allait droit c'est
un roc opposé ça va aller à fond l on va
mettre le rond b 1 peut-être pour
empêcher les velléités noir non g4 il s
dame un échec qui mettra juste le
cavalier en b1
renaud roy des deux incroyables le roi
qui monte les amis et là ça fait quand
même très peur il ya du tour à ses 8 qui
rentrent dam des trois dames français
trois dames france et trois cavaliers
quatre epr en c3 sévillans qui a
vraiment été présomptueux ici le roi des
deux dames prend b2 tour c'est 8
c'est quand même un cadeau il n'a pas vu
la pensée g5 que lecavalier serait
obligé de bouger mais malheureusement
non et maintenant dame prend ces trois
rois c1 et il va y avoir un petit fou
prend m6 et ça semble très très
difficile ici pour les blancs le roi
blanc est complètement en sueur les
noirs qui font des petits échecs
là il a tout calculé le roi qui va
devoir venir en d 3 e 4 échecs des vies
et on va gagner la dame sévillans qui a
vraiment fait une grosse erreur il était
en surchauffe le joueur américain et ce
coût et ce coût
g4 g5 laisser d'am-dam adam prend b2
c'était quand même un peu too much i à
+3 pour fear où déjà il reste vingt
minutes à jouer c'est à dire qu'il reste
à peu près six ou sept partis pour pour
sevian et j'ai envie de dire c'est
quasiment maintenant des balles de match
pour firoud déjà ou en tout cas
quasiment des balles de match parce que
le joueur iranien s'il arrive à +4 je
voulais du mal à avoir
l'américain revenir même si résiste
vraiment bien dans ce match
ici le poiré vite en f4 on veut surtout
pas faire re 5 sinon ça arriérés le pion
des six donc on va devoir jouer cavalier
cette fois ci c'est beaucoup mieux
maîtrisée de la part de firmes jazz il
semble en tout cas avoir un hérisson a
joué contre un hérisson de manière
vraiment agréable voilà ils réussissent
à faire ces cinq là le jeu noir qui ait
vraiment compris mais le pion aux cinq
qui bloque son propre fou et les blancs
qui donne l'impression d'avoir un pion
de plus c'est comme si c'était un vrai
pion de plus ce pion c5 et maintenant le
pion v5 qui va tomber c'est vian qui
arrivent plus saignant qui est dans le
dur cavaliers des deux maintenant vous
[ __ ] en bessin qu'on va revenir en d3
et on va ensuite tous ses cadres même
hymne à saucisse avec la tour qui tombe
la ja pions pour un f5 avec le pion e6
qui est cloué ça arrive vraiment de
partout il ya aussi b5 c6 qui est
jouable pour juste enfermé le fou là
tout est bon tout est bon pour firoud
déjà
ces cinq cavaliers ces six cavaliers c5
et les noirs qui semble complètement
foutu dans cette partie vide il veut
peut-être tentés c6 coupé 6 pour semi
s'activer non il fait cavalier h 7 jours
partir vers cavaliers g5 lequel qui
arrive en c5 menace cavaliers 17 masqué
promo 6 menace tous ses biens qui a
craqué il a eu deux occasions dès le
début de partie où ils pouvaient revenir
au score revenir à égalité mais là
malheureusement il ya cavaliers prend
des huit échecs qui gagne une pièce il
ya tout qui tombe et sévillans qui
arrive à -4 alors il n'a pas perdu en
utilisant beaucoup de temps au chrono
donc quelque part ça laisse encore pas
mal de parties pour revenir mais quatre
points d'écart si roux déjà très
dominant ça semble vraiment compliqué
maintenant pour ce evian qui doit
absolument l'emporter pour on va dire
espérer sortir au moins 1 un doigt de
pied de la tombe
mais il est vraiment bien au fond du
trou alors firoud de jacky continue à
bien jouer mais ces pièces au centre on
a l'impression qui domine des ouvertures
maintenant ils dominent tous cavaliers
p6 le pion détroit vous voyez qui
arriérés c'est à dire qu'il peut plus
être protégés par un pur évidemment n'y
a pas eu à me prendre et 3 il peut plus
être protégés par un pion et on voit les
pièces blanches qui sont tout de suite
pacifié elles sont vraiment très
pacifique
peut-être un coup comme cavalier à 5 ici
pour jouer cavalier b3 s'en prendre aux
pièces qui a et b 3 et peut-être kgs c5
par la suite ou d'un emprunt à 4 encore
plus fort et cavaliers ces cinq
peut-être maintenant pour provoquer l
échange des dames si c'est jouable
ça peut ça peut peut-être se faire ça
peut peut-être se faire le petit
cavalier c5 ici élégant dame c6 aussi
jouable le cavalier protégé par le fou
cavaliers c5 donc le coup élégant joué
par firoud déjà et max et ça me sévillan
pardon qui a déjà un pion de moins et
une position encore une fois difficile
le fou qu'il y en a 2 attention pas ta
main parce que réclame adp trois ans
ferme la dame la dame qu'il est en c1 et
maintenant peut-être fou p3 exactement
menace la tour il ya un clouage lequel
qui va revenir en eux quatre ils en
train de boire le calice jusqu'à la lie
peut-être ces cinq maintenant possible
non il fait fou tessin qui vient réviser
les cases les cases blanches
du rock et va y avoir du c5 qui arrive à
le pion et le pion est perdu attention
peut-être qu'à une petites imprécisions
de la part des noirs qui ont oublié ce
pion en c7 alors là sur food et 6 où va
la dame
non il fait un homme prend b2 aussi
possible donc il ya de nouveau un pion
de plus et il ya ce fou des six qui
rôdent peut-être un coup comme cavalier
f5 ici est jouable
je sais pas il faut voir parce qu'il
peut y avoir tellement de choses il fait
cavalier g2 et maintenant qu'est ce qui
valorise pierre fou des six qui semble
quand même forcé les changes des dames
qui semble le forcer un dame ces deux on
va pouvoir échanger et jouer et jouer le
pion plus surtout que comme je vous le
disais c'est plutôt intéressant pour le
joueur iranien parce que plus les
parties durent en fait plus on
s'approche de la fin du match et comme
il a quatre points quatre points
d'avance même une nulle qui durait très
longtemps serait complètement en sa
faveur donc là c'est une partie qui est
parti pour durer justement avec un pion
plus mais c'est des pions doublé donc
les blancs qui peuvent espérer la tenir
cependant c'est quand même tous les
noirs qui s'est quand même les noirs qui
met toute la pression du monde
kim est plombée quatre peut-être tour
akqa tour ces trois ouais c'est bien
joué ça la tour qui arrive en ces trois
cavaliers qui va être délogés et sur
wild 2 il y avait peut-être du cavalier
ou quatre échecs qui rôde et maintenant
la tour qui arrive en c1
le cari qui doit revenir vers 3 pour
protéger le pion non il part vers b2 et
maintenant le pion qui arrive en b3 donc
les blancs qui semble en grande
difficulté le cas échéant des trois
peut-être un coup comme tour c'est de
web bien joué et pion b2 maintenant au
qu'il veut faire tour b 4 qui semble
encore résister alors peut-être b 5e
tour c'est catway échange des tours
émanant b2b 1 c'est l'autoroute du sud
les mecs à la ccc l'a8 vers nice j'ai
envie de te dire b2 qui prend b2 c'est
la pièce de +3 et puis 3,7 kikoo facile
car ces quatre échecs cavaliers prend
des 6es firoud jha qui va l'emporter
ça fait plus 5 maintenant et le match
qui est en train de se terminer devant
nos yeux +5 je sais pas il doit rester
wade reste encore peut-être cinq parties
je calcule peut-être pas très bien les
partis se finisse vite mais il en reste
plus énormément et le score qui continue
d'enfler
fear ou jack qui semble absolument
imprenable en bullet c'est vraiment dans
les ouvertures directement y met la
pression tout de suite sur son
adversaire
la cavale et g5 la petite attaque de
nuit avec le 5e si c'est sûr qu'à vannes
et f6 fouet f3 gagne un tempo sur la
tour et on va retaper le pion aux six en
ayant créé une faiblesse en eux cette
fille roue de jarnac qui a pris le
dessus
que ce soit en terme de niveau de jeu
ils étaient déjà plus fort mais je crois
que psychologiquement
sam sévillans qui aura lutté toulon il
était il a été lâché les revenus il n'a
pas fait de fringale jusqu'à maintenant
mais là ça y est il a lâché mentalement
il était dans le dur il était moins fort
que son adversaire
il faut vraiment donner énormément de
crédit aux joueurs américains pour avoir
tout donné est resté dans le match parce
que c'était pas évident ils étaient
dominés il était on le sentait un peu
moins fort mais il restait il recollait
qui recollaient hirko les ir collet et
finalement le début de la section 2 1 +
1 il démarre à -2 il fait deux cadeaux
direct et c'était trop mentalement pour
pouvoir recoller face à un joueur qui
disons le franchement était simplement
plus fort que lui
plus fort que lui ce soir mais je pense
même plus fort que lui tout court et
donc c'est une victoire quand même assez
logique qui se dessine pour fear ou déjà
en espérant qu'on ait un way i avec une
bonne connexion internet afin de pouvoir
créer un match quand même sensation une
finale avant l'heure dans ce dans un
duel qui s'annonce vraiment incroyable
entre entre huy et firoud déjà roi prend
1,6 à cavaliers pro f cette fourchette
donc la fille rookie en train de
s'amuser avec avec son adversaire d'amd
de il attaque là ils attaquent la la
dame qui est bien placé il ya encore
quarante et une secondes
samse bianchi qui n'en peut plus
désabusé le joueur américain désabusé il
aura tout donné il aura fait un bon
match mais ce n'était pas suffisant le
fou qui va venir e4 par exemple à un
faille à tout qui gagne à tout reprendre
cette aussi la tour qui varient venger
sept la c1 cc du cadeau ouais ça me ces
gens qui a vraiment sorti un gros match
et prend f5
il a dû tout calculé jusqu'au match est
fou et 4 et dame prend f4 et dames f5
matt impressionnant une nouvelle fois
si round jackie le fini avec un match
fort c'est extraordinaire le joueur
iranien sur un nuage +6 maintenant le
match est plié les mecs 12 minutes à
jouer
les parties durent un peu plus de deux
minutes pièce à il joue marion tour gère
alors là dessus faut faire rue 5 est fou
aux six des 5 sata en khl avec g6 qui
est pas terrible pour les noirs ça avait
été jouée notamment 7 par an que j'ai 6
qui est pas terrible par kasparov contre
ivan tchouk est en tout cas il est blanc
il s'était retrouvé avec un avantage va
y avoir du f4 tôt ou tard et les blancs
là il aurait pu faire f 4 au coude avant
est carrément peut-être même gagner une
pièce c'est à cette thématique de ce
truc là zouk et prend des cats vous
prend des 4es ya un clouage et sur kei
c4 peut-être qu'il prend ses 6 pi et
prend des huit qui gagne est une pièce a
été raté par ces bianchi al'inverse deux
mois doit pas jouer cette variante là
tous les jours en tout cas il a faim
c'est censé être une mauvaise variantes
pour les noirs cette vente avec g6
mais c'est du bullet et c'est pas très
grave
ça me chante là que nous annonce que
pour le match de demain forest n'a pas
encore perdu
c'est ce que je disais c'est à dire que
si vous voyez une mauvaise connexion von
euw forrest peut créer l'exploit
sinon à mon avis c'est un faisable c'est
juste pas la même classe mais si ces
ventes forest qui affronte firoud déjà
vu que forest à mon avis est moins fort
que c'est bien ça va mais à mon avis ça
pas bien se passer
t'inquiète pas ça va bien se passer bien
se passer ne t'inquiète pas ça va être
compliqué pour le joueur pour le joueur
néerlandais donc là cette partie là bien
évidemment est un petit peu moins
d'excitation et d'émotion puisque le
match est plié les mecs
le match est plié ali minutes de jeu + 6
on n'a jamais vu une telle remontée
c'est un peu aussi même si même si dans
cette partie il est peut-être en train
de revenir
il va reprendre de fou il va essayer de
faire d'un point m6 faut faire f 5 kwh
ep on prend et fous des cartes pour
menacer d'un match 6 et dames g7 mat
trois chutes damage six tours g8 at-on
projets sise sur fg il y avait sept
matches c'est joli c'est très joli tour
pranger six âgées d'un match 6 ils
essayent de résister quelques coups de
plus tout rejet cette prise roi g8 donc
le roi maintenant qui est bien à l'abri
parce qu'il est protégé bien comme il
faut par le pion mais il ya quand même
une pièce net de - et noir qui ont
damage 4 et chez incroyable dame e4 il
ya pas mal d'échecs sur feu doux yade à
machin le retour sur wade 2 qui prend b3
roi des indes en f3 et c'est possible
qu'ils se soient fait retour aux menées
cavaliers prend b3 c'est incroyable
dames 8e roi prend g7
attendez c'est incroyable ce qui est en
train de se passer ferroudja qui a
peut-être tourner le truc il est
vraiment impressionnant la vitesse de
calcul de cet homme restait quand même
c'est un peu comme un peter poté pas il
est vraiment impressionnant et
maintenant il ya beaucoup de pions et
maintenant dame ces cinq peut-être pour
échanger les dames qui peut arriver
parce qu'il a il a quoi il a un deux
trois et il a tellement de pions
peut-être dame f4 ici qui va rôder
c'est incroyable et qu'avait lieu quatre
maintenant
ouais dame f3 il veut échanger comme ça
mais je me demande si je pouvais jouer
s'il pouvait jouer la finale
je suis étonné qu'il ait pas jouer la
finale contre les fous parce qu'à mon
avis il aurait pu échanger
il aurait pu tout échanger jouer la
finale avec la pièce avec la pièce de
moins mais avec avec l'armée de pions
bon alors cette position qui reste
compliqué mais hyper hyper hyper les
pions les uns après les autres
bon maintenant toute façon il alla nul
en poche
alors là ça va faire mal parce qu'en
fait f3 h 3f de fou prend h2 saddam
d'am-dam f1 dame prend à f2 et là ça
gagne avec la dame qui vient
attention pas en bessin direct les dames
c'est 8 sinon il y avait le pion qui
poussait et cfi round jackie l'emportent
quand même donc on était à + 6 et on
passa plus est alors que ces gens avec
une position complètement gagnante et ça
y est le match est mathématiquement
terminée
même s'il était même en cas de défaite
de fil rouge à mais le score a encore
enflé ouais c'est dommage
c'est dommage pour ces vian ouais c'est
eux c'est dommage a dû manger 51 grammes
de kidder et haricots verts et c'est
peter poté pas des échecs très bien
préparés et là mon avis c'est bien ça va
continuer c'est vian le capitaine
sévillans qui coule
là j'ai envie de dire il est en train de
en train de couler il a su et ils
croulent dans sa sueur c'est bien il
prend l'eau à il prend l'autre sa sueur
cyril tout à fait
le score reflète plus trop le match
effectivement un match qui était serré
c'est lyon qui a qu'il ya vraiment qui a
vraiment bien résisté de fort belle
manière il faut vraiment vraiment saluer
l'effort peut-être dame décès d'ici va
jouer à hay adams et cinq échecs par
contre mais bon il a pas mis le tanin
exactement le tan n'a pas tenu pour ces
gens il bouscule tout le monde
le tas n'a pas tenu et c'est dommage
d'en vraiment c'est dommage c'est
dommage parce qu'il fait un bon match il
fait un beau match mais il craque
il n'y a pas un truc et qui avait dit et
si cela qui va traîner
pas encore brel et 5 800 été serré les
trois plus en aussi mais finalement il a
craqué enfin il est bon il est vraiment
bon firoud déjà il est vraiment très bon
et on aimerait bien voir camille
victoire de séville en là pour un peu
plus pour que le score reflète un peu
plus le maquis reste 5 minutes
de toute façon le match est plié méfie
rouge à qui laissera rien passer un bien
évidemment voilà ça ça semble un peu
dangereux mais c'est bien qu'il ya
peut-être là tenir bon à vrai dire pour
en ce qui concerne le commentaire est
tout ça le gros du match et passer un
c'est bien entendu bien moins
intéressant que tout à l'heure une fois
que le que le match est plié
elle a la final qui va mener à la news
j'imagine alors ils disent que c'est
bien n'a pas gagné une partie depuis
depuis dix parties justement les 10
dernières parties sont dits défaite de
séville en farine 10 défaites
oh non il avait tout reprend à 7
il a il a raté trois sets en 1 à la
quelle cata quelle cata le pré move qui
a coûté cher
aie aie aie aie aie qui est dommage pour
ces vian à temps reprend 1,7 c'était
c'était son ami slicks qui voulut tour à
6 soit je ne sais pas mais mais bon
ralala seyante et est prêt mais c'est
dommage
c'est dommage que wes ces petites
occasions ratées qui font que le score
est aussi lourd même s'il mérite pas la
victoire sur le match mais trop fort à
la bêta qui arrive le quai qui va
prendre quelques pions des cinq qui va
pas tomber en réalité sur fou prend des
cinq as peut-être qu'un relief 5 qui est
très fort avec le avec un réseau ce de
maths sur le roi noir si route jacques a
peut-être une petite baisse de régime en
tout cas c'est tout ce qu'on souhaite à
séville en pour qu'ils puissent recoller
un peu gagné une ou deux parties là
en tout cas il prend car il ya cinq
dames b6 trois chiens et d'un même si
seul coup elle a peut-être carrillo 3
qui les prend des cinq fois cet échec
est tout reprend des cinq qui semble
gagner du matériel mais après trois
heures de jeu s'est trouvée
semble pas y avoir de défense et ça
pourrait le faire pour le joueur
américain keegan une pièce voilà tout ce
qu'on lui tout malheur qu'on lui cède
c'est de gagner cette position avec une
pièce de plus ça devrait aller mais bon
en bullet tout est toujours possible
la yamaha fz6 jusqu'à qualifier 6 échecs
fourchette
et oui donc est sûre et surgissent ici
gagne encore un pion donc à vrai dire
son avance matériel maintenant et d'une
pièce net avec une meilleure structure
de pions ça devrait passer pour pour le
joueur américain mais bon contre contre
fil rouge à il faut toujours se méfier
cependant maintenant c'est une pièce un
pion de plus donc l'avant ce qui grandit
il reste combien est-ce une minute rend
donc ce sera l'avant dernière partie de
ce match je vous rappelle que demain 17
heures on suivra le match de oui contre
vente forest je répète oui grand favori
mais mauvaise connexion internet la
dernière fois donc avoir à voir ce que
ça donne en fil rouge à qui la joue qu
il ajoute qu'il a joué peut-être temps
d'abandonner alors après peut-être qu'il
veut laisser tourner la montre et joué
une minute de plus pour pour que ce soit
la dernière partie je sais pas si calcus
ce genre de choses mais je sais qu'ils
jouent en bulles à être contre moi il
joue pareil hein il faut toujours
jusqu'au bout et laeta ya peut-être
mais fuite mater caron qui apparaît en
bas il ya un petit hic à roue et donc
c'est la dernière
qu'est-ce qui fouillent chaos bon il ya
un hic à rouen bat on sait pas ce qu'il
fait et hikaru bref si rogers ou
peut-être son classement de chez scot
melland la plus si ce vraiment un gros
match impressionnant vraiment deux
maîtrises m l'adamant h 5 h quatre
peut-être g3 f 4g trois fois je crois
c'est bien joué ça contrôle tout en
contrôle les pièces blanches qui ont
bien pris le contrôle de dessin kiev 5
7h 5h 6 aussi qui arrivent
ok détourage quatre tours g4 à venir à
il va y avoir des preuves si souhait et
oui ou là j'avais pas vu mais moi non
plus la jauge je cale un peu ça va
changer d'amis acoyer une qualité de
plus mais c'est complètement fini je
sais pas si il va la jouer jusqu'au bout
c'est vian ouais c'est dur il n'a pas
vraiment d'idée fire tour f 4 avec
quatre prises ah non ils sont forts
pirou déjà qui va avancer faut juste pas
se faire enfermer la dame et f5 permet
de de contrôler eu 6000 par avec la dame
a il fait un rêve cette c'est bien joué
ça ils échangent des dames
ç'a sûrement allez-vous mettre la tour
en a 7 ou 11 7
il va et changer pas mal de choses et
paroisse g7 et cavaliers de 5 la tour g6
par forêts pour échanger et là il va
faire du cavalier f5 g7
[Musique]
et 4e 5 et g7 qui arrive
ok faire rager 8 probablement au kéké le
seul coûte défense en réalité mais
maintenant les pièces noires sont
complètement mobilisé de ce côté-ci
round jackie joue avec le roi allèles
dame entourage 7 c'est bien joué et
abandon de ces viandes donc le match
qu'ils aient gagné avec sept points
d'écart finalement score un peu sévère
mais il a bien dominé le bull est donc
belle victoire de deux firent hodja on
sera de retour bien évidemment demain
moi je vais vous lancez un petit raid
sur la chaîne officielle de chess points
comme pour que vous puissiez suivre
éventuellement les interviews si vous
êtes intéressés et demain 17 heures on
se retrouve pour le prochain match
je vous remercie tous d'avoir suivi
c'est un plaisir de commenter ce match
pour vous et je vous dis à demain à
demain l'élite
alors là j'entends qu'on lance le raid
poursuivre les interviews et on se
retrouvera donc demain merci à tous
d'avoir suivi ce match
ciao les mecs